you are a guy who likes stories and
likes ideas so am I so today I want to
go through some of the best ideas that
I've learned from you over the last year
or so first one the frame matters more
than the picture what's that mean I
think often in life whether it's
marketing or innovation or when we're
building companies or products or making
content we fall into the Trap of
thinking that the thing we're creating
in and of itself is doing all of the
work to tell the story but when I looked
at tons of studies when I looked at
apples and art galleries and when I
looked at um Coca-Cola studies that they
did where they put Coca-Cola in a glass
and then Pepsi in another glass and then
did a different study where they showed
you which one was which it's so clear
that much of the work is being done in
Psychology not in reality what I mean by
that is if we just think about the Apple
Store every electronic store you've ever
walked into in your life is kind of like
a crazy Jungle of wires right that's how
electronic stores always were what Apple
did differently and which helped them to
justify the cost of a $22,000 smartphone
was they gave the the iPhone space in
the shop and we intuitively know that
real estate is expensive so the space
that the object is given actually pours
into the value of the object itself so
in an Apple store because it has two
feet e either side of it the frame in
which it's presented is telling you that
this item in the middle is high value
the the context you've always seen that
kind of framing in is an art gallery
where you have one off special pieces
the other thing I think so critical to
what Apple do so well is they only show
you one of each device and they keep the
rest in the back room if we think about
scarcity creating value things that are
perceived to be in limited Supply like
pieces of art whether they're typically
one-offs are seen in higher value the
frame in which you present something is
doing so much of the work to to
communicate the value of the thing
within within it um and even in the
Pepsi Coca-Cola studies which are Super
Famous from back in the day people would
rate the Coca-Cola drink more highly
when it came in the can and you could
see what you were drinking they would
say that's the better one but when they
removed the can and told people that the
Pepsi was a Coca-Cola or they had blind
um cups with nothing written on them
people chose the Pepsi the frame in the
story there and making people believe
that something tastes entirely better so
it's not just about value it's about
taste and sense and really at its called
pychology there's a story from Sam
Harris that I love which kind of takes
this from the business marketing into
the personal development space and he
says after you finish the workout
CrossFit or Brazilian jiu-jitsu or
intervals or whatever and you're laid on
the Flor panting making a sweat Angel
you've got the taste of metal in the
back of your throat and your hot and
every the Visions blurry everything
right that sensation although
objectively being quite uncomfortable
your felt sense of it is satisfaction
it's pleasure in a way it's very kind of
masochistic type of pleasure but if you
spontaneously had that happen while you
were sat in traffic you'd be [__]
terrified yeah you would ring the
ambulance and you would say I'm dying
this is a heart attack or a stroke or
whatever so the frame that we place
around our experience largely determines
our experience and the question becomes
why so as I talk about a lot from
looking at some studies that they did on
mice in a maze where they put chocolate
at the end of The Maze and then set the
mouse off they scan the brain of the
mouse as it's going through the maze the
first time and it's firing like crazy so
much activity in the brain as it's
sniffing everything and scratching
everything eventually it finds the
chocolate the second time in the Maze
they scan the mouse's brain they put it
back into the same maze with chocolate
at the end of it and it Glides through
the maze with no cognitive activity
appearing to happen at all it's gone
into autopilot and like when we think
about the the amount of cognitive load
that the brain would encounter every day
just when I'm in this room the amount of
things that I would have to think about
or or um to save cognitive capacity tune
out of what we know is the brain is
taking shortcuts and the frame and the
anchors around the thing you're looking
at provide tons of shortcuts so even in
the case of what I talk talk a little
bit about as well is if I gave in these
studies they gave people three options
do you want to go to an all-inclusive
trip to Paris or an all-inclusive trip
to Rome and in that study people go I
want the all-inclusive trip to Paris but
in the second study they say do you want
an all-inclusive trip to Paris or an
all-inclusive trip to Rome or an
allinclusive trip to Rome without coffee
people suddenly choose the middle option
the all-inclusive trip to Rome and it's
purely because this third option which
has entered the the frame has trick the
mind to think God if they removed coffee
from the all-inclusive trip to Rome the
all-inclusive must be way better because
they haven't removed it from the trip to
Paris a slight thing and we see it again
on menus and in electronic stores with
TVs and if you go into a a steak
restaurant and there's three staks
people will typically choose the middle
one because the the cheapest one and the
most expensive one of telling you a
story that the cheap one's too probably
not good the expensive one's a little
bit too bougie and that middle one which
is anchored in the middle in the middle
of that frame is probably the nice happy
medium between the two and this is
happening all throughout our lives we're
taking short shortcuts using the frame
to tell us stories of the thing that
sits within it people don't think about
the frame they think about the thing
they're creating but great artists great
innovators your Steve Jobs of the world
your Teslas of the world they obsess
about the frame because it's hard to
check like if you think about we want to
make an advance on people's perception
of our product the thing we've created
all the content it's really hard to do
that in reality like it's really hard as
Roy Sutherland says to make a train
faster or to make an iPhone better but
it's easy to play with the frame
to change the story in the consumer's
mind yeah this is where differentiating
yourself with whatever you choose to do
people get captured they obsess over the
actual thing itself whereas there's all
of these other anciliary extrinsic sort
of diffuse differences that you can use
and um yeah it's why you know I've spent
so much money to make this look pretty
because when people look at this it's
filmed in a different aspect ratio right
it's not filmed in 169 it's filmed in a
custom version of cinemascope right it
perfectly fits and I anybody that's
watching on an iPhone now turn it to a
wide screen and you'll see that it
perfectly fills there's no bars at the
top there's no bars at the sides it'll
even get cut off by the circle of the
bezel of the iPhone that's how perfectly
curated this is for the mobile viewing
experience should I say what I think the
most impressive thing that you do is
that's so tiny and it's actually just
four characters long hit me in terms of
the frame is you write in the title
4K nobody cares right objectively it's
not going to change the content uh the
experience of the content itself but
when you say 4K it's actually telling a
much bigger story it's actually saying
high quality high production value um
and really like the the second order
thing is there really worth your time
yeah we've invested a lot in this just
four characters it's taking in your
YouTube title but it's speaking about
the quality of what I'm about to watch
and I think that is probably doing a
tremendous work on retention and it's
just you just write 4K in little
brackets yeah but it says so much yeah
but I think when you're looking at
trying to compete with like you say
you're limited by the reality of
transistor size and circuit board
capacity and all the rest of it if you
look at the difference between an iPhone
and an I don't even know what the other
ones are Samsung or an LG or something
if you look at the difference the
Samsung and the LGs had features and
it's
had speed and megapixels and all the
rest of it the iPhone's still catching
up to but what don't you get you don't
get the experience you don't get the
status that's ass iated with it and all
of that is the alchemy that Rory talks
about all right next one next one you do
not get to choose what you believe how
is that the case this is one of the the
most I think probably the most important
things I've discovered over the last
couple of years because our lives are
essentially beliefs that we've accepted
as being subjectively true whether they
are objectively true or not um we our
lives are run on this instruction manual
of these beliefs that we've inherited
and when we're thinking about belief
change which is um what we need to do to
you know pick up a healthy Habit in the
gym or to build a business or to
persevere in any context it all comes
back to like okay how do I change
something that's limiting me how do I
change a limiting belief and how do I
adopt a new belief there's a a big sort
of contingent in the self-development
community that say you can go and look
in a mirror and you can recite things to
yourself and the Brain will believe
those to be true so there's a whole
contingent that say just think about
something and you'll believe it but when
I reflected on that in my own life I I
ask myself how many of my beliefs have I
actually Chosen and I used to be
religious up until I was years old I
believed in some kind of God
Christianity um and I I I zoomed in on
why that belief fell away what was it
and really what happened for me and what
I've come to learn is that um there
isn't a single belief I have that I've
chosen and I the experiment I'd ask
anyone to run that's listening to this
is think of a belief you currently have
in your life anything you have and ask
yourself the
question could you unused to believe
that right now if I if I put a billion
dollars on the table of Elon musk's
money and I said um I'm going to give
you this billion dollars if you don't
believe this hypothetical two pence coin
that I'm holding if you believe it's a
5p coin very simple there's a billion
dollars on the line and the reality is
you
couldn't you couldn't for a billion
dollars or if I held someone you love at
gunpoint you couldn't change any belief
you have you could lie I'm not talking
about Faith and Hope I'm talking about
actually believing it's true so if we if
we all agree upon that and I I ran some
surveys with people where I asked them
this question about 20% of people
originally thought um they could choose
their beliefs and then when I ran that
survey almost 99% of people realized
that they're not choosing their beliefs
where are my beliefs coming from well
all of our beliefs in my view are based
on the evidence that we've acquired
usually through our first party senses
sometimes vicariously from observations
and sometimes because they've come from
authority figures and figures in our
lives that we trust it's evidence that
we've accepted as truth doesn't mean it
is true but it's evidence we've accepted
um and therefore if you want to change
your Bel beliefs what's abundantly clear
is you have to go and put yourself in
situations where your existing beliefs
are counteracted with new evidence so
when it comes to speaking on stage or
when it comes to uh learning how to be a
podcaster or when it comes to
self-belief or whatever it is you have
to go and collide with new evidence yeah
Ryan holiday's got this amazing quote
where he says self-belief is overrated I
prefer to use evidence yeah exactly that
it gets back to that hosy quote I said
to Goggins right you do not become
Confident by shouting affirmations in
the mirror but by having a stack of
undeniable proof that you are who you
say you are outwork yourself doubt and
ultimately hoping that you're going to
be able to believing that you can think
your way out of a thinking problem is
like believing you can sniff your way
out of a cocaine addiction right you
have to give yourself something else
that's going to step change where you're
at I was hypnotized last week after we
met and that I said to her before she
hypnotized me I said can I ask you a
question do we get to choose what we
believe and she actually said yes and I
think she she interpreted different
she's a very very famous therapist
called Marissa Pier did you video this
yeah is it going out on the internet
yeah amazing 30 minutes it's hypnotizing
me to not eat sugar again okay to like
have a better relationship with sugar
okay yeah yeah yeah right um and it was
interesting because she takes me back to
my childhood and then confronts me with
the the information that my inadequate
lunchbox made me feel insecure it made
me feel a ton of Shame growing up cuz I
never had anything like we didn't have
food or like money or those kind things
so really my relationship with sugar now
is it's it's resembles power control and
fitting in the fact I can just order
whatever I want and eat so she went took
me back there and unwired that but what
she's actually doing is she's giving me
new evidence because she takes me right
back to that kid and she's basically
whis bring into his his ear a new story
and that's and so I actually think that
the principle that we don't get to
choose with what we believe still holds
true but with hypnosis which seems to be
the outlier they're giving you new
evidence that counteracts your current
beliefs that's all she did interesting
yeah so an important sort of caveat is
that new evidence doesn't necessarily
need to come from the external World it
can come from telling yourself a new
story about the things that you already
believe that you believe and that's what
hypnosis is it doesn't need to be first
party evidence that you encounter with
your eyes it can be someone else that's
very very skilled in taking you to to
that belief and smashing it I love I
love when this happens so let's think
about the two things that we've said so
far the frame matters more than the
picture you do not get to ch what you
believe what we're talking about here is
that your beliefs are largely determined
by the frame that you place around the
current moment and that frame given
professional help or a powerful
hypnotizer can end up being moved in a
way that also moves your beliefs yeah
right yeah that's very interesting when
she people think of hypnosis as like
someone tricking you into thinking
you're a monkey and then you start
clucking it wasn't that I was well aware
of where I was and everything going on
but she took me back to a hill I sat on
when I was four years old looking into
my lunch box and I felt like I was there
and then she told me a story a a
different story about that moment when I
said earlier that it's we've interpreted
it as subjectively true she gave me a
different interpretation on my lunchbox
and she then and that was the key thing
she gave me new evidence about an old
interpretation of an old situation and
that's what hypnosis does as an outlier
but for those of us that can't access
hypnosis the other way to counteract our
beliefs as I said is to you have to go
and put yourselves in situations where
you're going to be presented with new
evidence um and it's interesting with
belief change you'll accept evidence
that is complimentary as I said to you
you know if someone says you're more
looking than you you thought you were
it's shown in the studies that people
are more likely to move in that
direction if I said you're worse looking
than you are people are less likely to
move in that direction so even framing
the New Evidence as good news is a
useful tool for belief change the other
thing is if if we have 95% of the same
beliefs I'm significantly more likely to
accept one from you so when we need to
to embody a new belief going and getting
it from a source We Trust which
typically isn't our mother because we
understand the bias there there but
someone that we believe and trust in is
a useful tool for belief change as well
um and yeah I studied this really really
deeply I looked at why you could go up
to a child and say to the child I just
saw a pink elephant flying and they
might believe it but you couldn't say
that to an adult and they wouldn't
believe it have you seen those studies
that were done very unethical studies I
think in the 60s and 70s where they took
two groups of children and pushed onto
one the fact that they stuttered and
they would bring it up all the time and
they would point at them and point at
them and these kids developed lifeline
stutters throughout their entire
adulthood because they were told you you
mustn't stutter be careful you're bring
you're doing it again you're doing it
again yeah we're reinforced by what
happens in the world that's labeling
theory for you right and that's a form
of stereotype threat where you're told
implicitly that you are something so you
you accept it to be true and start to
embody it tell you what I found that was
really interesting people are more
prejudiced against those with different
accents than those with different skin
colors so this shows up again and again
in the
data and it didn't didn't really make
sense until I spoke to this evolutionary
Anthropologist and he said well think
ancestrally about how novel it would
have been to have met somebody with a
different skin color it's the tribe from
the next Valley over right it's not
somebody with a different skin color but
they'll speak slightly differently
they'll have slightly different words
that they use MH so we are predisposed
to be very prejudice against someone who
might look like us or might not but
sounds different and it makes kind of
sense so you know if someone's not sure
not believeing this think about what
happens some walks into the room with a
different skin color than you have but
the exact same accent that tells you so
much about this where this person's from
the background that they grow up in all
the rest of it and let's say someone
walks into the room who has the same
skin color as you but a vastly different
accent they've got a scous accent or
they've got a Texan accent and you go
wow like this person is very different
to me I just think it's professional
Prejudice any kind of prejudice so like
just
the Affinity that you have with the
person that's
yeah uh and it it shows up as in uh
especially in the UK which is a very
class-based system right America's
dominated by race but the UK I only
learned this when a friend came over to
the US from the US to the UK and he says
you guys talk about people being Posh
all the time it's like that's never a
term that I've ever heard I know what it
means it's never a term that I've heard
used in America never talk about someone
being Posh it's interesting because
Prejudice is such a context dependent
thing whereas if you're looking for a
100 meter Sprinter you know I'm you know
I'm looking at you if you're looking for
you say you can go through different
classifications and say who would you
want who would you be most happy or have
a highest Affinity to in different
contexts yeah and and it varies I'm I'm
really fascinated as well by like self-
Prejudice and the power that that exerts
over us and how in the studies that I
was reading if a um because there's a
stereotype that women are wor worse at
maths they did these studies where they
just ask you to tick your gender before
you do the test and performance dips in
women that have to tick their gender
same in with black people their
performance dips if they're just
reminded of their own identity if they
have to write their name the performance
dips so they did some studies where they
got people to change their name and
performance increased and it goes to
show that there's a stereotype threat
going on within us internalizing it at
all times and then the most importantly
is that when they removed those
stereotype threats before doing a test
performance was equal there was no
deterioration and I think about that
from labeling Theory and the harm grades
are causing all of us because me getting
e and D's yeah it's a miracle that I I
didn't interpret that as I'm an e person
and then show up in life in such a way
there's this similar quote from Anthony
Vino it's more socially acceptable to be
our own biggest critic than it is to be
our own biggest cheerleader and I really
coming from a British background I rail
against this sort of Zero Sum crabs in a
bucket tall poppy syndrome mentality and
yeah a lot of people might feel that
right
that you are able to say things to
yourself that you would never dare to
say probably even to the worst enemy
that you've got out there and you're
able to kind of create this designer
drug perfectly curated curse you know
exactly the scabs to pick you know
exactly the pain points you know all of
your shame and you're able
to you're able to point at it a thousand
times a day and remind yourself of it
and it's so strange it's more socially
acceptable to be our own biggest critic
than it is to be our own biggest
cheerleader I wish that wasn't the
I've been thinking a lot lately I've not
actually spoken about it but um in
trying to help some friends solve some
of their personal problems in their
lives where they seem to be in a
downward self-esteem spiral or are down
with discipline spiral it's always hard
to give advice and I'm actually cautious
about being a fixer something Simon Sy
talked to me about sometimes you just
need to sit in the mud with people but
one of the observations I've had is that
the path out of that despair is by
keeping commitments to yourself and this
kind of goes back to what you're saying
about the self story and what you think
about yourself every day I think when
I'm trying to give friends advice these
days what I say to them is the rewards
you get in terms of self-esteem and self
story what you think of yourself will be
correlated to the size of the commitment
you keep when no one is watching so if
you say to yourself I'm going to do this
when no one is
watching we don't think it's important
to keep those commitments we think lying
to ourself is there's no there's no sort
of um punishment for that I actually
think the greatest consequence in life
is not keeping commitments to yourself
and I think that compounds to as we
talked about where does beliefs come
from I think it compounds as personal
evidence which is deposited in this
instruction manner of who you are and
how you behave and how you show up and
what you're capable of all those tiny
little commitments and then I think you
can get into a downward commitment
spiral because of that because you think
you're a you know you don't have faith
in your own word you don't have faith in
anything you do and this causes a
downward spiral so isn't it really
lovely to know that maybe the way to
turn that into a positive upward
reinforcing spiral is just keep that
tiny commitment you made to yourself
today yeah like you don't have to move
move Mount Everest you don't need to go
on a sday Iowaska Retreat how about when
you said you were going to get in bed at
10: p.m. you do that Y and you stack
that you talked about Alex os's quite
about stacking evidence stack those
things for a week honestly I've seen it
in my friends and their lives have
changed the commitments we keep to
ourselves if we say those are the most
important things for compounding that
evidence in our favor everybody can
start there today like yesterday's out
of play but then the next thing you do
in the next hour can you keep that
commitment to yourself that's what I
think a lot about I think life is much
more simple than we often make out we'll
get back to talking to Steven in one
minute but first I need to tell you
about epidemic sound if you have ever
tried to put sound effects or music
behind any video you will know just how
hard it is to do epidemic sounds has
over 990,000 sound effects plus a vast
music library that will avoid any
copyright concerns your videos are not
going to get demonetized or infringe on
someone's copyright which happens all
the time if you're not using a
professional Library all of their tracks
are professionally produced by a diverse
collection of artists and are EX
exclusive to the platform if you've ever
been wondering how your favorite
creators take their videos to the next
level a lot of it comes with sound
design and that is the Sound Library
selection they have access to so many of
them are using epidemic sounds and you
can join them for free for 30 days by
clicking the link in the description
below or going to share.
epidemicsounds.com
slod wisdom and if you cancel within
that 30 days you can still keep all of
the sounds that you've used during your
trial period That's share.
epidemicsounds.com
modern wisdom the Mark Manson quote here
is the person you have to spend the most
time listening to in your life is
yourself try not to lose their respect
and self-respect and self-esteem I think
largely comes from having faith in your
own word so if you were to treat
yourself like a friend you are
responsible for helping which is
Peterson's advice right let's say that
every time you invited a friend out for
lunch they turned up late or didn't turn
up at all they didn't text back they
just kept not holding to their word
after a while you wouldn't believe in
them you wouldn't be friends with them
and you'd stop inviting them out to
lunch you are that friend to yourself
how on Earth do you think that you're
going to be able to move mountains and
get out of that relationship that you
don't like and move countries or change
career when you can't not hit snooze
even though last night you promised
yourself that you weren't going to hit
snooze and it's how people that are able
to do extraordinary things have been
able to get there that they've just
started off unbelievably small right I'm
just not going to hit the snooze button
I'm just not going to use my phone
before 9:00 a.m. right these are
controlling your thoughts is
unbelievably difficult and requires a
lot of meditation and maybe psychedelics
controlling your actions is relatively
easy especially stuff like don't pick
your phone up before you've gone for a
walk just try that in the morning
sunlight before screen light as huberman
says and that's the easiest way to
control your thoughts yeah because
there's a two-way relationship between
what you do and how you feel absolutely
so if you want to change how you feel
focus on what you're doing if you want
to change how what you're doing focus on
how you feel but but you said said about
extraordinary people there this is what
Chris Eubank Jr said to me which really
stuck with me he said my dad flew me to
Cuba um and they we had a training camp
out there and they surprised me they put
the the heavyweight champion of Cuba in
the ring with me he's not he's like a
middleweight or something he gets in the
ring This heavyweight storms across to
him knocks him so hard he flies out of
the ring and hits the floor dead leg and
he's laying on the floor he said he said
to me I looked up at the ring and I saw
this massive Cuban heavyweight stood
there and he said I realized in that
moment that I had to get back in the
ring because if I didn't it would let
the demons in and another instance of
when he talks about the demons more
specifically was on his story about the
treadmill he goes if I'm running on a
treadmill and I get to mile 9 and I get
complete cramp in one of my legs and I
know I've told myself I'm going to run
10 kmers today he goes I will have to
limp The Last Mile even if no one's
watching because I can't let the demons
in and if I let the demons in they'll
show up in the 11th round of a
championship fight when there's 50,000
people watching me in the audience and I
know deep in myself story that I'm the
type of person that quits when things
get hard because I got off that
treadmill at Mile 9 when no one was
watching it would modify myself story
The commitments we keep to oursel and
what we do when no one's watching is the
most persuasive evidence that governs
everything we then do every day
thereafter and this is for me was a huge
Revelation in my life because you know
you can look at certain people in your
lives that are struggling in certain
situations and often times it's a result
of continually unkempt commitments to
themsel yeah I don't know anybody who
has done extraordinary things that isn't
keeping their word in that way right
there's consistency doesn't guarantee
that you're going to be successful but
not being consistent will guarantee that
you're not successful let let me UNS
Superman let's like the mess of this is
some people are remarkably good at
keeping commitments in some areas of
their lives and hopeless in others so
they'll have kind of dual self-esteem
they'll be incredibly you know confident
and secure in their work but in
relationships or whatever else they'll
be Ground Zero and I'm very much one of
those people that has areas of my life
where I have immense commitment and
you'd say I such a disciplined person
and then other areas of my life where I
res being hypnotized out of sugar you
know what I mean yeah i' actually
haven't eaten sugar since as well so it
did kind of work I have no desire to
have sugar anymore hell yeah so no I I
know exactly what you mean and this is
something how you do anything is how you
do everything is a a lovely quote and a
lovely idea but it piles an awful lot of
pressure on you right and it's very easy
especially as we said it's more socially
acceptable to be our own biggest critic
than our own biggest uh like
complimentary given
that if you mess up a little bit that
can quite quickly spiral oh I I Chris
said that I shouldn't check my phone
before I go for a walk in the morning
therefore it means that I might not as
well go to the gym and I might as well
like break my alcohol streak and I'm you
know all of these other things yeah
finding this balance of being robust
enough and delicate enough with yourself
to say okay I know that you tried well
let's get back on the horse again
tomorrow right it's it's a delicate
balance right holding yourself to high
standards whilst also being sufficiently
supportive and this is the same in
business so it's not you don't break
trust when you don't do what you said
you were going to do you break trust
when you don't do what you said you were
going to do and you don't own up to it
take responsibil responsibility for it
and point it out so in business there's
often times where you say something to
your team and for whatever reason
mitigating circumstances that thing can
no longer happen trust isn't broken at
that point trust is broken when you then
don't sit in front of your team and say
this is why this didn't happen and at
the same I think applies to yourself
you're going to miss some things in life
but taking responsibility for it staying
empowered and not saying oh I couldn't
do that because or I needed d d d no it
was your priorities it was the
priorities and the decisions you made so
when I miss my commitments the Saving
Grace for me is I go I did that that was
me that was a choice that I made and if
it's a choice I made or didn't make it's
a choice I can make in the future the
what you see in that chapter is you see
obis of
responsibility um you see blame you see
excuses and you see disempowerment in
the form of language like I couldn't
because you know or I needed to or which
I think is scary language what's the
difference between parrots and
practitioners which just something I've
been thinking a lot about I I've
observed the
most successful
intelligent creative
Innovative apparently original people in
my life and people that aren't even in
my life and the the consistent thing
amongst all of them and in my businesses
is that those that are truly exceptional
and that over any extended period of
time when you zoom out achieve
disproportionate levels of success start
with this kind of boring drudgery of
obsession over their craft driven by
this deep passion and curiosity I mean
Jimmy car's a prime example of that
leaving his his potentially lucrative
career to go and tell jokes for for no
money for 10 years Darren Brown left a
great potential career and Pathway to
becoming very very successful in a sort
of typical sense to go and do card
tricks on a table in
Bristol everyone's story when when I the
people that I admire that are the
masters of their craft were these deep
practitioners and then you have this
other type of person which I call kind
of the parrots where they observe these
people in the learnings that these
people have given them and they kind of
just regurgitate what they're hearing
but they never do the time to practition
so they never get to that deeper level
of understanding and as they say you
know to learn something you read about
it they often say to to understand
something you write about it for me I
think to understand something in this
context you do it and you do it in this
iter iterative pattern for many many
years and your depth of understanding
once you've done something is
unparalleled and that's the foundation
for great creativity you see it with
Fred again he's what a guy man he's he's
an absolute in my mind he's an absolute
genius he's a [__] Savant for the
people that don't know who we're talking
about Fred again is a classically
musically trained DJ who's put turned
his hand to like Tech and house music I
suppose but will also happily get up on
the roof of his flat in Hackney or
wherever it is and play a completely
solo set classically on piano a keys you
see the conviction of that and you see
the the first principal nature of his
work where he's doing something we've
apparently never seen before of course
he's taken inspiration points and he's
using equipment that was already made
before he was born but he's pulling the
pieces together in new ways and that's
what creativity is and that kind of
creativity belongs to people that have
gone right down to that first principal
level you're talking Elon Musk you're
talking y cany of the world and Fred
again where he's pulling things together
in different ways and expressing himself
without the constraints of convention
that's what that's what pioneers and
practitioners do and Pirates can never
do that because they don't understand
the seaf Flor they just play with the
boats on top of the water there's a
quote that I've fallen in love with the
magic you are looking for is in the work
you're avoiding yeah [__] dude the magic
you are looking for is in the work
you're avoiding and every single time
that there is something in front of me
that I I feel like things aren't coming
my way sufficiently quickly I'm not
making the progress that I want it's
because I'm [__] about over here and
there is a large frog in front of me
that I need to eat I need to spend
another half day reading a book I need
to spend some more time researching
online and upping my skills in this
particular area I need to do whatever it
is can I do you know what's interesting
is most intelligent people I've met no
the most successful ACT people I've met
as entrepreneurs and
practitioners never read never really
read
books like even in Elon Musk of the
world I know he watches movies and stuff
he gets his inspiration points from many
areas but thinking about the great CEOs
that I've met and the great Founders and
the great artists I've met there's
almost
a you know I think I said this to you
earlier on that knowing too much can be
a real disservice to innovation in
creativity like knowing too much innov
information whereas this sort of
practitioner pathway where you naively
stumble through new territories seems to
be more conducive with the real Pioneers
I wonder whether that's the curse of
knowledge in a way you familiar with
this yeah Stephen pinker's idea of the
curse of knowledge that when you start
to learn things you can't understand
that other people don't know it and you
also lose the learner's mind in some
regard which is you're not lucky you
said about you come into this room and
there's a million bit bits of
information that you could be focusing
on but you're not focusing on those
you're focusing on the ones that matter
mhm and I think that when you start to
kid yourself that you know what you're
talking about you're no longer quite as
open to these new ideas I would say the
difference for you know our industry
what we largely traffic in are anecdotes
and insights right and they can come
from experience but I also like exposing
myself to new ideas from other people
and the quickest way to do that actually
know this is a Lie the quickest way to
do that would be to permanently be going
for dinner with interesting people but
that's like an unsustainable life it
would be like 2 hours of dinner with
Douglas Murray then Jimmy C then Steven
Bartlett then like it that would just be
my existence and I'd just hear oh yeah
and that's cool and oh yeah what about
that and oh I've never thought about
this before like that would be the way
I'd do it but in lie of living this
Perpetual dinner life reading books is a
a good second for me yeah it's a good
second I just think about the things
that I couldn't even express in Words
with my vocabulary that I know about the
art of marketing and human psychology
and why why people do what they do like
and the the experiences that are all
fundamentally intertwined in the
mistakes that I made in the Journey of
getting there now in a book I might give
you like the the four paragraphs but the
rest of the iceberg yeah is the
foundation of the thing that sits on top
of it and you think about podcasting we
both came into this industry I'd say
fairly late compared to like the rest of
the industry right but because of that
there's a naivity to it which allowed us
to do new things um because we didn't
read the book yep um that I think some
of the radio industry are struggling
with with that transition dude I mean
you're seeing it in a America The Late
Night show hosts are trying to Pivot
from heavily scripted heavily supported
by writers and a production team and
researches and all this stuff and then
you put them down in their garage with a
mv7 bus powered microphone in front of
them and you realize oh like these
people don't have any skills Beyond
being able to be very good at reading
the script and that's a massive skill I
couldn't do that you put the script in
front of me I'm going to fall to the
floor but yeah what's the takeaway here
though for someone's listening to this
now and they're a young person and
they're at the start of their career or
even if they're not necessarily a young
person for me the takeaway is to go and
fail at something that's high value in
the future as soon as you can with it
with with the least amount
of potential cost to yourself it's like
to go and practition if I had kids now I
would tell them to go and join an AI
startup that that's well funded that's
what I tell them to do small group of
people where they're going to be close
to the information and and the the
evidence and I'd tell them to go fail in
a high value future industry that's the
thing I would do if you want to be a
master but then okay they have to pick
an industry that they are innately
passionate about because you won't go
for a decade with Fred again or Jimmy
Carr or Darren Brown's curiosity if you
don't you're not innately captured by
that thing but I think we are looking
for cheat codes I think much of the
reason why people probably listen to our
stuff is where we want we want the three
tips how can I growth hack my personal
development you meet anyone like you you
meet Jimmy or you meet dar and you go oh
15 years no money in busking the pal
think about this I wonder and I ask
myself this question a lot I wonder how
much of the development that we really
value in ourselves isn't because of our
own agentic highly Sovereign approach to
marshalling our own life I wonder how
much of it just comes along for the ride
as a byproduct of getting older yeah
you're just this was going to happen
anyway and maybe I sped it up a little
bit and maybe I can you know create a
nice story about why it happened but the
most wise people I know it's very rare
that I meet somebody who has who is much
older than me that doesn't have wisdom
that's come along with it which suggests
that wisdom is just there for the ride
right as a byproduct of Aging but yeah I
would say takeaways from this aim to
focus on executing so the the four
disciplines of execution really
interesting analogy that's used the word
strategy is in the top 10 of all
LinkedIn words in BIO descriptions and
execution and execution
aren't even in the top 1000 right
because it's much easier to strategize
than it is to execute but if you this is
a term that's you can tell people that
really know business when they use it
one of a few terms talking about someone
being a real operator right that's you
go oh okay say no more like I know
there's someone that will get things
fixed right that they're able to take
charge of whatever the challenges that's
in front of them and our mutual friend
George Max's got this beautiful idea
I'll ask you this one actually so the
way to work out who the highest agency
person in your life is have you heard
him do this before no [__] brilliant
okay so you are trapped in some South
American jail right and you're about to
be transported somewhere where no one's
going to be able to get you back let's
[__] Columbia Argentina somewhere
right you have 24 hours and you only
have one phone call to ring somebody to
come and get you out who's that person
that you
ring
oh
Prince
[Laughter]
William right okay I feel like you've
broken the game a little bit there I
don't think that was that was perfectly
Fair do you know my framework though was
find someone that is both smart and
influential member of the royal family
yeah and that cares enough about my
predicament yeah so but that that the
the framework that you come up with
there if you don't know the Future King
of England is someone that is able to
think on their own that doesn't need
instruction that is going to be able to
solve problems at a very high level
Under Pressure very quickly you know
just all of the things that you want in
a friend yeah it's so true it did you
Whitted it down to five people
instantaneously in my head and I was
deciding between them but I thought I
don't know if they can pull enough
levers [__] Prince William yeah
you've got an idea that's kind of
similar you must become a plan a thinker
yeah and just on that last point it just
popped into my head then that I think
what I'm saying here is that no matter
what you're aiming at over the next 10
years in your life I think this horrible
realization that bucks the trend of
every Instagram quote you'll ever read
or every course you'll ever buy is that
the fast way is the slow way because the
slow way is the only way like I I stood
behind fren again this weekend as he did
his show Ali P to 10,000 people or
whatever it was and I'm looking at this
guy going I want to do that I want to be
able to do that but my better sense from
interviewing all these smart people
knows that it's not case of me doing a
court it goes my my brain now goes are
you willing to put 20 years of Silent
boring drudgery and Obsession into doing
that my brain goes no so separate out
the aspiration from the adir I got to
show you this I got to show you this so
Mark Manson put this quote up a few
months ago and I've not been able to
stop thinking about it the most
important question you ask is what pain
do you want in your life what are you
willing to struggle for anything
worthwhile is going to require some
degree of pain and struggle
so if you're oriented toward the pain
and the struggle you're probably going
to be more aligned with what you're
capable of accomplishing rather than if
you just Orient toward the
pleasures so good because we say find
the thing which you enjoy the most but
really what you're finding is what is
the pain you're prepared to swallow the
most nothing worthwhile is going to come
without discomfort you know even for me
and you love doing the show love
speaking to all these interesting people
people get to fly around the world and
all but I would be lying if I said I
love writing show notes or doing
research in Guatemala airport at 3: in
the morning because I'm on a delayed
flight and I've got a flight I've got a
episode tomorrow like it's grind it's
grind that I care about and it's grind
that I can do that other people couldn't
do but it's not not grind right this
goes to the discipline equation which
yes you might be I'm familiar glad hit
it hit it because that that really
embodies it that Mark Manson quote about
the pain you're willing to encounter um
I was figure out why there's some areas
in my life where I'm disciplined and
other areas of my life where I seem to
lack discipline kind of what I was
saying earlier about being a dualistic
type of individual and I came up with
this discipline equation that I'd love
to interrogate with you because I've not
thrown it at enough people to know that
if it's if it's true or not so
discipline
equals
um the importance of the goal plus let's
just say the importance of the goal to
you so the subjective importance of the
goal how much does that goal matter to
you plus the psychological enjoyment you
get in the pursuit of the goal right so
as you pursue the goal how
psychologically enjoy enjoyable and
reinforcing you know is that for you
minus the psychological cost of the
pursuit of the goal so I can I'll run
you through some examples Simon Sy said
to me well Steve I take the bins out at
7 a.m. in the morning yesterday um I
didn't want to do that but I did it so I
go okay let's run that through the
framework what would happen if you
didn't take the bins out that under that
sort of underpins and defines the
importance of that goal well he get a
fine and then he up have an overflowing
bin out the front of his house so the Y
is high the psychological enjoyment of
pursuing taking the bins out is very low
right and the friction of getting out of
bed at 7 a.m. is high but thankfully the
why is so strong that regardless of the
fact that the pursuit the enjoyment of
the pursuit is low and the friction is
high the behavior still occurs going to
the gym learning to DJ in all areas of
my life I can run it through that
equation and go okay so in the pandemic
the reason I've been going to the gym
for three years straight now is because
my why surged the the the percept of the
importance of that goal surged I saw how
our existing Health correlates to our
health outcomes and I realized for the
first time in my life this clear thought
that I couldn't unshake that my health
is my first Foundation it is this table
that everything I love and care about
sits upon so that has to be my number
one priority reflected in my schedule so
that that changed that went up the
psychological pursuit of going to the
gym is kind of enjoyable there's a bit
of a dopamine release there and it's fun
to do that feels good for my self-esteem
and the friction associated with it is
low in less and unless I go to a gym
where people know me and I spend the
whole time talking then what I what
happens if I'm put in that situation so
I don't go to the gym the discipline
equation changes so part of the reason I
made a big investment in a company
called until is because I can have
somewhere I can work out and focus on
the workout genuinely that that's one of
the things that actually changed my
relationship with the gym and nearly
threw me off the Habit y was that
psychological cost so how do you how
does that sit with you it does there
you've got the discipline equation death
time and discipline yeah what's the
Death part so
like when I started writing that
particular chapter in my book to
understand discipline you have to
understand the scarcity of time because
you know so I started because I was
going to write a a chapter about time
management people want to know how to
manage their time and as I went through
the hundreds of available time
management techniques I realized the
promoter technique the time blocking all
this one two three four the ABC the
reason why there's so many time
management techniques is because none of
them work unless you have this
underlying thing called discipline it's
the same in The Fad diet industry that
industry will always churn out new
things because there's an underlying
issue which is discipline so it's kind
of a mirage industry so the chapter
pivoted and started focusing on
discipline well the next thing was time
um why is time important round the
numbers if you're how old are you now 35
okay so you have if you reach the
average age of an American you have just
over 177,000 days left to live and I
think all of that goes to show
that time is the currency we're playing
with in every moment of Our Lives it's a
sense point of our influence I talk
about the roulette table of my life it's
it's the frame I think through where we
wake up in the morning with these 24
chips if you spend 8 hours sleeping you
wake up with six 16 chips left and how
you place those chips on this roulette
table that sits in front of us just
before the wheel spins every day
determines all of our outcomes in our
lives so I've chosen now to put to
allocate two chips to this little piece
here called Fitness the roulet table
spins and I get my returns as I went
down that chapter I realized that in the
context of time and death um and time
management the most important question
to answer the fundamentalist discipline
how can I allocate more of these chips
to the things that are in line with my
values where does This Thing Called
discipline come from if it underpins
everything we do it even underpins what
you just said there with Fred again in
that Mark Manson quote the reason why
Fred again is doing that is because his
discipline equation is in is in is in
line if for whatever reason you just
tipped any part of that equation you
could knock him off that discipline yeah
with with Jimmy car and with all these
people that go do that decade of
dedication to become Masters in their
craft if you look to their discipline
equation you'll see moments where the
friction came up and they fell off or
they got writers block or whatever it
might be called in their context um and
then so you can influence your
discipline if you understand that
equation when my DJ equipment was on the
floor of my spare room I did not dj use
it the minute I put it on my kitchen
counter and had it one button away from
being able to practice at any given
moment I put it right in front of me
same thing for any Creator if you're
starting to do a YouTube channel and
this is this is a life hack here do you
remember you might have had this in your
house when you were younger radio uh
infrared soer Turner honor us it's like
a single remote it's like 10 bucks on
Amazon and you leave the wall socket on
at all times and you run it through one
of these additional sockets and then you
plug your [__] into that thing and you
it's like 10 bucks right on Amazon my
entire Studio at home is run through one
of these so I go in and I just press 1
two 3 four and everything comes on
because when I was first starting out it
was super effortful for me to set up the
camera and I'm going to do the thing and
I'm already trying to learn to do
YouTube and it's terrifying and I'm
looking into this black lens and it says
precisely same as you DJ kit can't be on
the floor if you want me to practice as
much as possible make get it in the way
put it in the way of things right it's
almost harder for me to DJ than it is
for me to to to avoid it this it was on
my kitchen counter so I would sometimes
be going into the kitchen to eat
something and just oh um press the
button and just I'm off four hours later
I've just done a 4-Hour DJ practice Yeah
if you think about give me something in
your life you're disciplined at and
we'll run it through the equation
something you've shown great discipline
at recording the podcast recording the
podcast does it really matter to you yes
is there psychological enjoyment from
the pursuit yes is the friction High
what's what's the level of friction four
out of 10 four out of 10 but if we added
up the first part of the equation how
much does it matter to you out of 10 10
and how much how much what's the
psychological enjoyment of the pursuit
nine so I'd say we're about 19 takeway
four and because it's positive the
behavior will occur you can do that as a
minus four right the behavior will occur
if at any point the friction gets really
high and for whatever reason if the
pursuit of it or the the why behind you
you know the subjective meaning behind
it falls the behavior will not occur
I've heard you do this with your
meditation practice yeah which is why
you're not meditating yeah exactly my
why isn't strong enough I don't I don't
I haven't quite had the the evidence
inic enjoyment it as well sometimes we
need a little bit more pain right it's a
it's a robus in way to to frame it I
guess if Alex was sat here he would say
we might say a lot of people are driven
by pain rather than pleasure right 100%
And that's the why part the chip on your
shoulder accounts for so much it can
account for so much right um you know
somebody who had really bad period of
mental health they suffered with anxiety
attacks and it lost them something or
somebody scorned them and they go oh
okay and then they decide to commit
themselves to mental health and
improving the texture of their own mind
that's coming from a place of wanting to
prove other people wrong well whether
someone is driven or dragged is
impossible to tell on the surface and
I've sat in my podcast over and over
again and asked people are you driven or
you being dragged by something when I
say dragged I mean some kid on the
playground at 7 years old told you
you're a scumbag and you'll never be
anything and you're poor and then that's
dragged you that insecurity and that
shame has dragged you to
entrepreneurship into becoming a
millionaire driven is what you know Gary
vuk describes to me where he says his
mother loved him so much and she
encouraged him so much that he had that
drive to kind of like prove her right
whatever force it is it comes down to
why which is the start of the equation
and
in t of Shame as Aid the only blackid in
an all white area pretty much the
poorest family in our street definitely
dilapidated house in in the context of a
wonderful area deep shame and insecurity
about not being enough drove me like
you've like I was an obsessed hungry dog
for it's still doing it now in the back
room somewhere you know one of my
favorite quotes that I've heard from you
recently is this I was riddled with fake
Ambitions my ambitions were fake they
weren't ambition they were insecurity
most of our lives are dragged by
insecurity and shame they're not driven
by ambition and it's a tragic truth that
most of us are going to have to have our
Ambitions and our narratives fail us
before we realize that there Illusions
and mirages and they're false 100% And
it's I have belief sometimes that a lot
of people disagree with um but and I
think this is typically one of them
because people want to take control over
their success they want to have that
sort of power over it but if I I
remember sitting with Eddie Hearn and I
remember what Will Smith said and they
all describe they can all very clearly
articulate the reason for their their
motivation and their Drive they live in
a world where every media reporter will
say oh you're so amazing like tell me
how you're motivated every day it's not
the case I actually I question how much
choice they have over that motivation in
the case of Eddie Hearn he lived in the
footsteps of his father Barry Hearn who
pulled up to school in these
rolls-royces and he was known as Eddie
hearn's son he's competing with his
father he'll say it I'm driven I'm
dragged by the insecurity of of being
Barry's hearn's little son and I want to
outdo him it's the same with some of my
other B billionaire friends and it's the
same with Will Smith he's being dragged
by an insecurity and shame so the key
thing because that's not always a bad
thing right in in every context of life
it might make you arrive at Financial
Freedom sooner than others but you just
want to make sure that you're cognizant
of it at least in my life I realized at
about 24 years old when we had an offer
from a very big company to sell the
business I went home that day and I
googled mansions and lamborghinis on
autot Trader and I looked into that
screen and F felt a deep sense of
emptiness like I'd been betrayed by
somebody like someone had lied to me and
it was true someone had lied to me
18-year-old 12-year-old Steve had told
me that that would fix everything and as
I played out it arriving on my doorstep
I realized that i' would be poorer if I
bought it some I'd lose something I'd
lose my company and the community and
the love I had but I'd lose something
else then I went through this six months
of sort of existential crisis of like
okay so if it wasn't for that
if if we weren't obsessing like a dog
what the [__] was I doing it for and um
my fear this woman came into my office
one day and she said to me just imagine
for a second you have everything you've
ever wanted she goes because the truth
is you do there's no goal that you
haven't completed that you need to
complete to be worth more and I remember
walking away and thinking what a load of
rubbish two years of dwelling on that
thought and I arrived at this conclusion
I think because I was scared of this
idea that losing my drive would would
lead to no ambition but it's very much
the opposite
it losing your am losing
your losing your insecurities and your
shame that's dragging you
doesn't dissolve your ambition it
dissolves your fake ambition and creates
room for your real Ambitions that are
internally intrinsically motivated so
instead of wanting a Lamborghini in a
mansion I wanted this whole set of other
things when I realized that the
Lamborghini in the Mansion were never
going to make Steve Bartlett worth more
than one Steve Bartlett deeply in me I
genuinely think part of me thought that
if I got Lamborghini in a mansion Steve
bartett would be worth two or four Steve
bartletts but your your your currency is
one of one and so in that moment once
I'd realized that nothing was going to
change the intrinsic value of me I could
focus on things that I would do
regardless of that P perception of value
fluctuation like starting a podcast or
um learning to DJ or doing a musical up
and down the country or joining a
psychedelics business just to learn for
a year about mental health and
psychedelics and the funny thing is if
we think about Fred again and Darren
Brown and all of those people that
achieved Mastery from a decade of
natural dedication is that's Al also the
path to real Mastery when you're not
being dragged in other news this episode
is brought to you by nomatic no
literally it's actually brought to you
by nomatic that carryon Pro is the hand
luggage that I used to transport my
laptop and all of the stuff that I
brought with me to the UK the difference
between having proper well designed
durable highquality luggage and not is
everything it makes the difference
between packing a compl complete hell or
actually quite enjoyable the teamut
nomatic creates the most functional
durable and Innovative backpacks bags
luggage and accessories everything from
nomatic comes with a lifetime warranty
which is exactly how confident they are
in the quality of their products
especially if you're someone that
travels quite a lot you need to make
sure the luggage you're using is high
quality and nomatic is the best that I
found so if you need to upgrade your
luggage game for work for travel or for
anything else the first place to go is
nomatic head to the link in the
description below or go to Nom matic.com
sodern wisdom and use the code modern
wisdom at checkout for 20% off
everything sitewide that's Nom matic.com
modern wisdom and modern wisdom a
checkout the thing that's interesting to
fold in here that I think is
useful most people have more pain than
they do anything else especially when
they're starting out I don't think when
you very very first beginner Pursuit
you've got this perfectly balanced
desire to maximize your guy and show up
in the way your logo's being spoken
forward is supposed to it's not people
took the piss out of you from being
different in school or your parents
didn't believe in you or they coddled
you too much or you don't feel like you
were given the opportunities that you
should have got or you failed yourself
or other people failed you that's
[__] power that's fuel right and you
know what it can be as well it can be a
tiny thing oh throw away comment throw
away comment lunch money oh yeah and
that taught you a story going back to
what we said about evidence about money
and other people and that has just
dominated your self story for the for
the next three decades a story you learn
about money you know so I think that
that fuel is toxic especially when used
for a long period of time but I reckon
you can get a good five or 10 years out
of it and I think that to get yourself
past the activation energy to go and do
something in the very very beginning
it's all well and good for you or me to
sit here and say ah you know you can
find the balance in the way that
everything works like we've been through
that fire let's neither of us kid
ourselves about what got us here in the
first place it was [__] resentment
right I had a desire to prove everybody
that had ever picked on me in school
every person that thought I wasn't going
to amount to anything everyone that had
ostracized me socially I wanted them to
regret that decision don't get me wrong
and it's only been after a long long
long time of realizing that actually
if it wasn't for the fire that they'd
given me I wouldn't have got to where I
am now which is a place that I'm
incredibly proud of so I should thank
them oh that's a [__] interesting
realization and here's the here's the
risk though and what I came to learn is
it will take you somewhere that drive
but it's not guaranteed to take you to
happiness and the the obsession of being
dragged by an insecurity like the one
you've described and the ones that I
describe is so overpowered ing that it
might mess up your priorities and and I
think at a deeper level humans
regardless of their we do need these
fundamentals to be happy we need that
sense of connection we need
relationships we need all of those
things and in my case I work seven days
a week in that Bloody office I would
come in even when I didn't have anything
to do because there was a deep sense of
sort of self-esteem associated with my
work the cost was I didn't speak to my
family for two for two years the cost is
like even as I sit here I haven't spoken
to my mom for months like we fallen out
the cost is I have very small group of
friends and the cost is I've spent years
struggling in relationships and I'm I'm
I'm now 31 I've managed to get in a
relationship and rep prioritize my life
urgently but the cost I see in a lot of
people I meet is okay they're successful
in one of nine metrics of happiness and
I sit there with I've sat there with
some of my close billionaire friends
they got all nine cars that I've ever
dreamed of rning up outside and they
tell me at 4:00 a.m. by their indoor
pool that they're deeply unhappy and ask
me to sleep in their bed with them that
night because they're lonely I don't
disagree I don't disagree that if you
scale this for long enough it's not good
for you right but it is so potent at
getting that activation energy in the
beginning and I just don't know if you
were to take me back and say you can
dispense with your fear of insufficiency
the chip that's on your shoulder all of
those things I don't know if I would
have done anything I don't I I think
that I would have been significantly
less motivated to go and to be able to
deal with the
uncertainty of the Lonely chapter so I
came with this idea with hosi a couple
of weeks ago called The Lonely chapter I
[__] love it
so there is a period in everybody's
Journey where they are so different
because they've started to do new things
that they no longer fit in with their
old set of friends but they're not
sufficiently developed that they've
gained their new set of friends and
they're unsure should I go back should I
lean back into getting a bad game with
the boys on a weekend is that the
highest you know know way that I can
live my life passion forward because
that's what everybody else does and all
of my friends are taking the piss oh not
drinking again too good for us are we
not going out again this week oh okay
well like enjoy staying in home and
reading [__]
nerd so you're going to feel the pain of
being ostracized from the group of
friends that you used to have but you're
stuck in this messy Middle where you
haven't yet worked out who you are on
the other side of this and that lonely
chapter that's in the middle is
something that I I would say almost
nobody that I've ever met who has gone
from a place where they are to a place
where they want to be hasn't gone
through are you out of the Lonely
chapter yes yeah
100% uh I it's difficult for me to find
it it's difficult for me to find it
again facilitated largely by being in
Austin um but that being said most of
the work that I do is on my own you know
I I spend hours sat at my desk
researching sorting stuff for episodes
dealing with the team making sure that
everything is set for this trip or the
next trip or whatever we've got coming
up I think High performers actually they
they do exactly what you've described
there they leave the the tri the
comfortable tribe that you know is
social expectation and their childhood
friends whatever else and once they
leave there there's that initial point
of resistance and then I think they to
some degree live forever in the
loneliness chapter the start of it is
much more difficult but there's so few
people that that can relate to their
experiences once they come out of the
the crowd anyway that they're always
going to live to some degree in a
heightened sense of sort of loneliness
they can find a tribe at home and with
family and with a partner but it's never
the same as having you know what you see
other people have from your hometown
well that's you know look at any bell
curve right the fattest bits right in
the middle and to move yourself out to
the edges
is to accept being alone in some regard
alander boton's got this quote where he
says loneliness is a kind of tax we have
to pay to atone for a certain complexity
of mind yeah there's two things we don't
want to be not enough and different it's
what a therapist said to me recently
that came on my podcast she said there's
two things that fundamentally I
interview billionaires and CEOs and
royalty sorry she goes I I'm a therapist
for billionaire seos and royalty she
goes the two things are that people
struggle with fundamentally are feeling
different we don't want to feel
different that's a rejection from one's
tribe which used to mean back in the day
through a process of self-preservation
we'd die earlier as you you've heard
about in the studies of you know that
they did at Harvard um would get more
ill our immune systems would break down
and the second one is not feeling like
you're enough which means you're not
valuable to the tribe so not being part
of the tribe of good or of good use to
the tribe causes a bunch of signals in
our body which then manifest as
physiological disease and psychological
disease so at at its call sometimes I
think when I'm feeling in that such a
way maybe I'm feeling lonely or I'm
feeling really different or some I've
got some feedback which makes me feel
like I'm Different in a fundamental way
I just ground myself in the
understanding that even the fact that I
feel that makes me like everybody else
and um in terms of loneliness I've had
to kind of carve out my own new tribe in
my life a very small group of Prince
William H yeah but no moving moving to
Austin was a big part of that for me
because I was
around it's
a city of cultural immigrants yeah right
everybody has gone from one place to
this place so that is the selection
effect and that's why you know again
another great way to work out who's
agency in your friend group is are they
living in the same town that they were
born up in or in a new one are they
living in the same country that they
were born in or a new one have they
decided to do something on their own and
take risks that they were the only
people who they were responsible for um
in relation to your riddled with fake
Ambitions thing this great quote from
Alex that says you've already achieved
goals that you said would make you happy
yeah and that encapsulation of the honic
treadmill in a single tweet I think is
so interesting
it but it also calls you to refrain what
you're what you're pursuing and this is
why the part of the discipline equation
the psychological Pursuit is actually
really a nice thing to focus on because
we both know in all of our Lives even
the the podcasting game you're playing
now there's not finish line here is
there every day is the finish line so I
I think it reframes what we're aiming at
because there are mirages that move off
into the distance as we approach them
yeah and if you if you become too think
about unhappiness coming from unmet
expectations if you're too focused on
the the the podium giving you pleasure
when it doesn't the expectation that it
would could lead to unhappiness what
happened when you hit a million Subs how
did I mean i' sit down my team I go I
know none of you really care but the
reason why we should celebrate is
because and then I give them the reason
and it's same with 3 million when we hit
3 million Subs same thing walked into
the back room of our studio I go listen
I know this doesn't actually matter what
matters more was the old lady that came
up to me when I went to penguin the
other day and said that was almost
crying in the lobby that's what we all
care about we care about the Chris Kamar
thing where he came on the podcast then
his former football club put banners up
in the stadium about it we care about
impact and this is just a a a trailing
metric of impact so um it's important
you know I've done a lot of research
over over the last 10 years about how to
build a company in such a way where you
don't get those moments of burnout or
anticlimax and Simon Sy talk talks about
B building things as if they are
infinite so how would you set up you and
this podcast team through the frame of
we're going to do this for a 100 years
what you you design design this system
to be sustainable over over the long
term you'd aim at consistency You' try
and optimize intensity but not at the
cost of in consistency and the whole
system of how you treat the people and
how this everything and how you treat
yourself would be set up in such a way
that's what I think about now I'm
actually thinking about our podcast
through the lens of heavily inspired by
what Joe Rogan's done sticking at that
for like 15 years how do we run this
game for 50 years and I think that's a
huge competitive advantage to think
through that frame because there would
be a lot of people that would have
designed their systems in a way that is
not sustainable and I see it with
podcasters all the time I see it where
they've you know they've got four mates
who are all on the podcast and they're
doing it twice a week well then what
happens when Jerry you know has a
divorce with his wife and has to leave
and then it was the system was never
designed for longevity so all facets of
my life my companies my teams all
designed for longevity 90% of podcasts
don't make it past episode three really
and of the 10% that do 90% of them don't
make it past episode 20 so by making 21
podcasts you were in the top percentile
of all podcasters ever in history and
how many get past 10 years of [__]
hell that's the game I want to play I
want to I want to do a 20 20 30 year I
said it to my team all time multi-decade
systems long-term games with long-term
people so my team can move through the
chapters of their life right they're
going to be fathers and mothers they're
going to get you know they're going to
have certain moments in their life where
they have health risks and is our system
designed to guide them through that but
retain the talent that we want to retain
um is it is it designed for for a
changing world that's going to get AIC
Centric like do we have enough uh fast
acting feedback loop so we know when the
next thing's coming would you not just
slot people in and move people out like
the differences and the challenges that
you're going to encounter at 10 million
Subs is going to be different to what
you encounted at 10,000 Subs so I don't
know I get that and there will usually
be a core group of people but really the
only core thing is you right ultimately
if you want to start
doing Stadium Edge shean Style
Productions the people that did the
first Steven Bartlett tour they're not
the people that can do that right you
need new people you need a different
cinematography team and you need people
that can do live broadcasts and they
need to be able to do switching on this
huge [__] desk camera 3 camera 4 like
I I don't disagree but fundamentally
what it seems to me it comes back to is
how can you make sure that it's your
infinite game yes it trickles down to
the rest of the team but ultimately the
team are going to come and go the only
thing that's going to remain is you CU
if you go it's it's [__] done you're
not selling Diary of a like Diary of a
CEO now presented by [__] Jimmy car
like it's not happening so in that
sentence there was a key thing I said
which is the talent you want to retain
and in building businesses I've built
businesses from 0 to 700 I always know
that the first phase one people the cult
we call it it's the cult the growth and
then the Enterprise phase three stages
in business and then you have the
decline which is inevitable for all
companies in the cult phase the people
that can wear multiple hats and that are
fired up and sleeping under the desks
are not always the people that thrive in
the Enterprise phase where there's your
your your job description is very very
narrow you need to be very process
orientated and fit into a bigger system
they're not always the same people but
the people you want to retain that have
a decade of information capital in their
heads about who we are the disciples if
you think about C Ferguson there's a
reason why he kept Gary Gary Neville on
the pitch and Gary Neville has told me
this directly I've seen the conversation
he had with CeX Ferguson where he asked
him the question gaffa why did you keep
me around like three or four years after
IID I clearly couldn't kick a ball
anymore and it was because of he
represent he knew the culture he knew
the values and you need disciples all of
those players all those man united
players said to me how many times do you
reckon Sir Alex Ferguson came into the
training ground dressing room in 26
years I said I don't know for 2000 they
went twice why because my disciples were
in there I didn't need to go in when
cultures are strong they're self-
policing when cultures are strong new
people become the culture when a culture
is weak the culture becomes the new
people so in in my teams I want as many
people that were there from the jump if
they have the capacity to move through
those phases of growth and um and the
key sentence was the talent I want to
retain yeah you must sweat the small
stuff why I just I just think uh just
think it's the most important thing I
remember one of the most important books
I ever read was the slight Edge by Jeff
Olsen when I was 18 years old um because
it helped me understand the importance
of marginal gains and the tiny things in
life and how they're compounding for or
against you invisibly in every aspect of
your life your teeth your skin your
finances your relationship the tiny
things are compounding for against you
and the the analogy I give to help sort
of illuminate this is if you didn't
brush your teeth today no one in this
room would know if you didn't brush your
teeth every day this you might I might
because I'm in close proximity if you
didn't brush your teeth every day this
week really you a couple of people might
notice but they wouldn't say anything no
real costs if you didn't brush your
teeth every day for five years your
teeth would fall out you'd be on a
dental chest screaming and the question
becomes when did that happen it happened
today it was that small seemingly
invisible decision which was easy to do
and easy not to do as they always are
that you chose not to do that compounded
invisibly against you and as they say in
compounding returns which they call the
eighth wonder of the world according to
Warren Buffett um it's slow then it's
fast and that's why it's so difficult
and so easy to overlook the smallest
things it's easy to save one pound so
it's also easy not to I believe that
most people in any discipline I'm
competing in will not sweat the small
stuff they'll Overlook the small things
which gives us a great competitive
Advantage um by obsessing over the
smallest things and also as we talked
about earlier we talked about the frame
and how it's hard to it's really hard to
make huge steps forward in reality but
much easier to make them in Psychology
it's very difficult to find big steps
forward in business it's very difficult
like think about us as podcasters is
there really like another platform we
could go on to we're both on airlines
now I think we're both on YouTube
Spotify and apple is there like a
breakthrough step forward we if there
was we'd all be doing it right they're
hard to find small things though I can
stack a hundred of those and make a 100%
gain as Sir David braford said and the
unobvious thing that no one thinks about
is the psychological impact on a team
when you stack small things this is what
we call the progress principle Harvard
Business Review interviewed thousands of
people in work and said when was your
most enjoyable day in work and they all
pointed out in their Diaries a day when
they had a sense of progress even small
a tiny little gain they made sir David
bford who's known for his marginal gains
Theory and has written about in the
first chapter of James K's book Atomic
habits said to me yeah the the small
gains the making the water bottle just a
little bit bigger and the pillow softer
mattered but the thing no one gives us
credit for thing no one talks about is I
took over a team that were depressed
psychologically they were down and out
they didn't want anything and by finding
tiny little gains quote we felt like we
were going somewhere that psychology of
momentum is the greatest force in
business I can I can tell you in all my
companies now which ones have that
feeling of momentum and the impact in in
6 12 182 four months that'll have on
that their excellence in their work and
their delivery in terms of bottom line
and I can point at the companies now
that don't have that I call it it's I
say it's in the air they don't have the
momentum in the air the collective don't
feel like they're going somewhere the
easiest way to jump start this like I
said about keeping commitments to
yourself is to go and find tons of small
things and share them with the group and
Sir David bford said to me we started
finding all these things small things
and what you'd find was people were
staying till 2: a.m. because we were in
the in the in the shops making the tires
a little bit bigger and people were
fired up we felt like we were going
somewhere how do you apply this to your
personal life this the small stuff I
just see this it goes back to what we
said about letting the demons in I see
the small things that I do is they're
all compounding for or against me so
this morning when my girlfriend got out
of bed and walked out of the room I
remember thinking like we developed a
habit and we're developing a habit now
where we don't interact first thing in
the morning we say good morning to each
other we used to always this sounds a
bit soy or whatever but it's the truth
when we first met when we woke up we'd
cuddle just for a bit we're kind of
tired with cuddle we moved out of that
and I can see if I just zoomed out over
the last three years how our Behavior
like our our interactions in the morning
are just veering off so this morning she
got out of bed and she was walking off
and I go hey come back come back I said
let's have a cuddle and we laid in bed
for about 20 minutes and just cuddled
that's that course that subtle course
correction which they talk about in
aviation was it the 611 rule where for
every 60 mil you fly if you're one
degree off Target you'll miss the
airport by one mile that that need for
that's also why the small stuff is so
important it's that continual course
correction of that compounding curve
that's dominating areas of your life
you're not thinking about and if I just
give you that lens of every area of your
life your relationship your health your
teeth your skin your money is subtly
compounding in One Direction based on
the tiny decisions that you're choosing
to make or not make and the way that you
can change that trajectory over the next
10 years is by saving that pounds
brushing your teeth taking care of that
relationship checking in with that
friend and if you zoom out on you know
you look at Warren Buffett and how he
made his millions it's all that it's all
this obsession with the compounding
returns which he calls the eth wonder of
the world so his business partner
Charlie Monga says the first rule of
compounding is never interrupt it
necessarily yeah so that so this is the
other side right you must sweat the
small stuff but when you are sweating
the small stuff stop [__] about with
it right are you on a path it's the same
for me like a lot of the questions and
stuff that we've had over the last year
is like what are you going to do next
what are you going to change what's the
next project a big part of me is like
everything is so vertical like line go
up and to right right which I know you
know the feeling of I I really don't
want to touch too much this doesn't mean
that we're not looking at different
ideas you got this this is a different
way of shooting things it's in a much
smaller room actually trying some
different angles we're shooting on
different cameras blah blah blah but
it's not a massive change right the
first rule of compounding is never
interrupted unnecessarily and so many
people
I think because there is an allure in
the novelty of doing something new like
oh yeah maybe I'll try like I'm sure I
could start a [__] VC firm or some
[__] or like start it with a friend
or like be like Stephen like how should
I begin to do this thing it's like look
one thing the thing that you've said is
already most important is going up and
to the right stop [__] about with it
right the compounding is on your side so
it's temptation is highest when we're
unsuccessful and when we're successful
it's not it's not high in the middle
because when we're unsuccessful there's
so much alluring us away my mother
started 25 businesses before the age of
me being 25 because her when her
business was struggling someone would
walk in and tell her that estate agents
down the road and making loads of money
so my mom literally started an aate
agent she couldn't access the internet
she couldn't read or write so she
started that and then someone walked
into the shop six months in and said
warehouses that do furniture down the
road is selling lots of money so I
watched my mom start 25 different
businesses at and then at the top let's
look at the top so when you go when
things are going really well and temp
Temptation optimal as well if you think
about the biggest podcasters in this
country previously I won't name them cuz
I don't want to but the thing that took
them off their Throne was
diversion even true Jordi the other day
did a tweet where he said um somewhere
along the way I lost
track of what my job was which was to
give value to my
audience London real [__] hell he
changed his YouTube channel to be to run
for mayor and he posted at at times it
looked like 30 video iPhone videos a day
still the same
Temptation was high the temptation of
becoming London mayor so I think when
I'm an optimal Temptation Focus stop
[__] about Focus don't interrupt the
process as Charlie Munger would say this
episode is brought to you by eight sleep
we have decided to land in the UK during
a heat wave and every Hotel I've stayed
in the airon has broken I thought I'd
left Austin so I could escape the heat
turns out I haven't and the Pod cover
from eight sleep would have been a
lifesaver the Pod cover sits over the
top of your existing mattress just like
a normal mattress topper and actively
tools and heats each different side of
the bed based on yours and your
partner's sleeping preferences As you
move through sleep stages it'll change
the temperature to ensure that you stay
in deep Sleep it is the biggest game
Cher to sleep that I think I've ever
found the Pod cover even tracks your
heart rate variability your resting
heart rate your sleep stages your sleep
consistency it's like having a wearable
built into your bed they also deliver
internationally and if you are not happy
with your pod cover within 90 days for
any reason they will give you a full
refund you can get a $150 discount plus
that 90day money back guarantee by going
to the link in the description below or
heading to 8sleep.com
slod wisdom that's EIG ghts sleep.com
slod wisdom I fell in love with an essay
by strangest Loop and it is a list of
things that are not doing the thing so
here is a list of things that are not
doing the thing preparing to do the
thing isn't doing the thing scheduling
time to do the thing isn't doing the
thing making a to-do list for the thing
isn't doing the thing telling people
you're going to do the thing isn't doing
the thing messaging friends who may or
may not be doing the thing isn't doing
the thing writing a banger tweet about
how you're going to do the thing isn't
doing the thing hating on yourself for
not doing the thing isn't doing the
thing hating on other people who have
done the thing isn't doing the thing
hating on the obstacles in the way of
you doing the thing isn't doing the
thing fantasizing about all of the
Adoration you'll receive once you do the
thing isn't doing the thing reading
about how to do the thing isn't doing
the thing reading about how other people
did the thing isn't doing the thing
reading this essay isn't doing the thing
the only thing that is doing the thing
is doing the thing and I love this
Insight that you can dress it up however
you want the work just needs doing and
you can fluff it and you can change it
and you can talk about compounding But
ultimately it comes down to sitting at
the desk and answering the email opening
the word document recording the podcast
and one of the things that I found is a
really great hack for me I would have
none I would have no success as a
YouTuber that I've had being a podcaster
because I work well when I have someone
else in front of me like I would clean
my room at home if mom came and sat and
like just watch or talk to me right
because I I just didn't want to [__]
do something that sucked on my own being
a YouTuber and staring down the lens hi
guys welcome back to the channel today
we're going to [__] do whatever we're
going to do I really really struggle
with that sitting down with someone else
in front of me that makes it easy so
there are ways that doing the thing can
become more easy but ultimately the work
just needs
doing really highlights the discipline
equation but but also all of those
things in that essay really pointed at
procrastination and there was hints of
um trying to realign one's cognitive
dissonance by announcing to the world
that you are something that you know is
not consistent with your actions but one
of the things that I really got from
that was people think we're motivated by
Pleasure and if you when I sat with Nel
who wrote the book on distraction and
procrastination and why people do it one
of the really key messages I took way
was that we're actually motivated by the
avoidance of
discomfort and like so I I quizzed him
on it I was like really okay so sex he
goes yeah horniness is a form of
discomfort so you're motivated to
relieve yourself of the horniness and if
you look at any aspect of your life when
you're procrastinating cleaning the
house or you're procrastinating doing
the essay so you end up cleaning the
house it's because that's the path of
less discomfort you we're motivated by
the avoidance of discomfort this is
really useful because if you want to
understand why you're procrastinating in
some area of your life the most
important question is tightening your
self-awareness on the thing that's
causing the discomfort because in most
areas where we procrastinate we have no
idea we're just avoiding it do you think
do you ever think about the weird [__]
that you do when you're procrastinating
from the thing you're supposed to do
yeah
like I have an essay or an email to
write that I don't want to write or I
need to reply to someone that and it's
an awkward an awkward conversation or
something like that and guess what now
my cupbo sources are perfectly aligned
like you will find the most inventive
way is to not do the thing I I I noticed
this about myself I flew to Barley to
write my latest book and as I was in the
jungle I noticed this pattern where
every time I picked up my phone like
just see needlessly was because I was at
a hard point in the book yeah so every
single time I'd be get I'd get to a
point and I was trying to summarize it
or find some research to back it up
within 30 seconds as if I'm possessed by
this Puppet Master above me
yeah pick up the phone start swiping and
I'm on Instagram and I and I go [__] of
course I'm avoiding the disc comfort and
it's so important to get clear on that
because you you need to understand the
forces that are pulling and pushing you
and then you can say to yourself okay
why am I avoiding this chapter what is
it well I don't feel researched enough
on this subject matter okay well I'm
going to step away from the computer and
I'm going to read that book or watch
that YouTube video as opposed to just
banging my head against this word
document you can if you become aware of
the discomfort you can counteract it but
if you're not aware of it it's just it's
an an object you just can't hit so that
that changed my life that question what
is the psychological disc Comfort I
avoiding right now you must make
pressure Your Privilege so pressure is a
privilege is on a lot of t-shirts by
Chris Bumstead who is the current Mr
Olympia classic physique Champion he was
on the podcast a little while ago made
t-shirts with pressure as your privilege
on it turns out that one of my best
friends in Austin his godmother first
came up with that the're tennis player
yeah yeah and sued Chris no and I was
like oh yeah her book is called pressure
pressure is a privilege this is awkward
yeah that the guy that I and it was the
first question I asked him and then I
spoke to Sky and I was like have I has
there been has this recreated some
trauma inside of the family is
Thanksgiving dinner going to be ruined
because I brought it back up again but
yeah you must make pressure Your
Privilege
why you look at any aspect of Our Lives
where we experience growth it's under
pressure there's an old cliche adage
about how Diamonds Are Made which I
think although is cliche speaks to this
in such profundity and even when we
think about the Comfort crisis we're
living in and all of the health outcomes
and predicaments that we're facing
through our obsessive um pursuit of
comfort and how the body has started to
break down and we've got all of these
mismatched diseases they call it where
the world we're living in and the way we
behave within it isn't aligned to who we
who we are um it's the avoidance of
pressure and it goes back to what you
said earlier about avoiding that
difficult conversation or that difficult
piece of work if if there is an
antithesis to pressure it is in my mind
it is Comfort it is ease and that means
that today is great and tomorrow is bad
and anyone that has the foresight to
have move that discomfort and that
pressure into the current moment yields
much greater returns in terms of
happiness and health in the long term
and in the book I go through tons of
examples from Health from Sports to
Everest climbers who understand and that
famous tennis player who was the best in
the world and I still think she is the
the best female tennis player in the
world um it was her Mantra it was that
what is your relationship with
difficulty and everybody including
people in my family who have a adverse
reaction to difficulty just defer it
into the future in a bigger way it
compounds against them to make their
future harder than their present so
everyone's relationship with difficulty
whether it's difficult conversations or
difficult workouts or difficult physical
psychological exertion um those
individuals I think are setting
themselves up for a brighter future well
how do you deal with the discomfort that
comes along with pressure though right
you
have okay the fact that I have pressure
pressure means that I care about
something it means that it's fulfilling
to me uh there are people that go
through their entire life and don't ever
have anything that approximates like
importance right and I have it but the
felt sense of pressure isn't that the
felt sense is overwhelm and chaos and
concern and and there's a a story below
those words you've just used that really
is the problem it's I'm not good enough
I'm going to be kicked out of the tribe
I'm Different all of those things right
those that's the base layer the
pretation you're right there's a story
We Tell ourselves about our pressure
which determines how we experience the
pressure I actually did if you look at
that famous Ted Talk on stress and
pressure what they found out is that
stress and pressure don't actually kill
people unless you believe it will you
have a negative interpretation of your
pressure and your stress then it shows
up in your physiological response you
get more diseases but in that famous Ted
Talk which I think has like 30 million
views she found out that pressure in
itself isn't the problem it's the story
We Tell ourselves about our pressure
that causes us to be unhealthy healthy
um and we all have different stories
about our pressure and if and if your
story is that it is x y and Zed it's
going to get me kicked out of the tribe
it's going to expose myself for not
being good enough if your story about
difficult situations is I'm an impostor
versus this is a growth moment not only
you going to show up worse you're going
to perform worse and the physiological
impact and psychological impact is going
to be detrimental and that's what this
whole argument about imposter syndrome
is so confusing to me because if I asked
anybody would you like a life where you
were never outside of your where you
never did anything that challenged you
or pushed you would you choose that no
so why are you complaining about your
life being full of that I think anyone
who has a healthy relationship with
pressure goes in search of continual
imposter syndrome like you know what I
mean like and they would be they would
be dismayed at a life without it without
that pressure and feeling out of your
depth well the presumption would be that
you're never doing anything you haven't
done before right there are people that
have imposter syndrome which I call
imposter adaptation which is your
impostor syndrome persists despite the
fact that you've disproven it at this
very thing it would be like every single
time that you did a podcast you being
adamant it was going to be terrible and
you were going to fluff your words and
and [__] yourself and say something
racist right it would be like
everything's going to go wrong despite
the fact that you've got 300 400 [__]
bits of proof that that's not the case
MH but imposter syndrome should show up
in someone who's healthily moving
forward into new areas that they haven't
been in before like imposter syndrome
largely is a very realistic assessment
of wow I've never I have no proof that
can do the thing that I'm trying to do
like what did you expect do you have
Blind Faith and over time what you end
up with what really good robust
confidence is is
when analogous
situations start to bleed into other
ones you spent a lot of time during
social chain doing onstage speaking
which presumably gave you even just a
tiny little bit of a base that oh well
like podcasting is kind of not not a
million miles away from being on stage
and being on YouTube's not a million
away from being okay so it starts to
sort of bleed into these other things
and that's when it's really cool and
that's when you get real compounding of
confidence confidence evidence yes yes
that's what we said earlier talking
about criticism you've moved from like
being rich in an independent media way
to now being famous in a very sort of
normal traditional media way as soon as
you accept the Dragon's Den
deal that is you allowing yourself to be
noticed by the guardian and BBC and all
of the rest of these people what have
you learned about the differences in
scrutiny and ten between these two
worlds when I was a podcaster or a CEO
um I wasn't of public interest at all
that's actually the legal definition the
word public interest when you become and
you become part of a BBC show you
legally become public interest what's
that mean means that people can write
certain things about you that they
couldn't otherwise that's the ACT it's a
legal term so if you were to for example
sue a newspaper um they would make a
case that we could say that about him or
we could reveal his private business
because it's of public interest they
wouldn't be able to do that for someone
that wasn't on on the BBC so that all
all of that stuff changes the things
that you have to keep the same and I
think this is the same for everybody is
you need to keep your circle of
information your circle of feedback
tight and close and small you have to
put systems in place and I think this is
actually the this is what Jo ogan's done
really well and I've heard him speak
about it at Great length is you can't
search your name online which I never do
I don't search my name on anything not
Tik Tok not Instagram not YouTube
nowhere because it's it's for me like
the there's a set of principles and
there's a there's a set of principles
which are more important which is like
me being true to myself and delivering
in my way the feedback can be really
distorting because it's not necessarily
like always helpful so someone could
comment on something that I produced and
say this is terrible this is is Dreadful
you need to do this this this and this
now if I take that feedback violate my
principles we end up in a place which we
talked about earlier where you lose
focus to go for the decade which I
talked about the systems I'm setting up
in my life you have to limit the amount
of feedback you get which is not not not
easy but you've had a few periods where
the Press have been a bit buky and and
accusatory and attacking how have you
dealt with the the felt and what's that
been like you know you you've you're a
young guy like you've gone this world
where you got to be rich and largely
Anonymous although you weren't totally
Anonymous but relatively now very much
changed how do you deal with that as a
felt sense of it's systems and processes
again it's like even my friends right so
if my friends see something on Tik Tok
or Instagram or if it's like about my go
whatever do not send it to me I will not
see it and I again I've I actually took
a lot of advice from Rogan's system
Rogan's the same none of his friends can
send them anything I don't see that
stuff cuz it's it's not useful
information and the truth is and again I
spoke to Simon synic about this you
don't want to
start aiming at ghosts you don't want to
start exerting energy on trying to
counteract public perception
um which isn't necessarily based on even
their own perception of reality anyway
you don't want it's not a useful ex sort
of way to allocate your chips I talked
about those 24 chips have 6 enough when
you wake up it's a really inefficient
use of your time doesn't bring you
forward in any way so it all comes down
to systems and processes you need these
principles in your life which take you
right back to your caveman days when
there was 20 people and you all your
survival led to the survival of the
other 19 people so in in my hardest
moments when I'm being criticized or
scrutinized or whatever for me that's
what it comes down to it's like keep my
circle super small focus on what I'm
doing you know Rogan's solution was
Heavy kettle bell workouts five minutes
of cold therapy and three grams of magic
mushrooms per day really yeah I heard
him say that when the spot fight yeah
correct yeah and that's I mean that's
his system he's and he's built up like a
social network as well to guard him from
you know news and articles and feedback
and stuff and he he's kind of retracted
from like social media as we know I
don't think he was ever huge part of it
and I understand why what would you say
you know people from the outside looking
in at somebody that gets the accolades
and can hang with Prince William and
make breakfast in a pratt or whatever
what do people not realize about the
reality of the sort of scrutiny that
comes along with big platforms
especially mainstream platforms
um I would i' probably draw more on
other people's experiences than my own
from like interviewing people that have
dealt with like real Fame because I
don't consider myself to be really
famous um I think it's maybe just never
maybe there's a you probably experienced
this as well but there's like an ongoing
always on
paranoia which I think is just this
numbing paranoia in the background and
also this realization which is actually
something I learned from that one day by
the way where I was with Prince William
we're not friends he doesn't know who I
am
but when I spent that day with him and I
posted I've just been with Prince
William we did this bu business
initiative every single message I
received was amazing how is he amazing
is he nice amazing is he nice amazing
was he um sociable it's this realization
that everyone you meet you're meeting
everyone they
know and and that's that's a that's a
lot of pressure to never have a bad day
in public and it actually gives me huge
empathy for someone like Justin Bieber
who is actually famous who goes out in
public on his worst days and tries to
pick up a can of milk and there's 74
Paparazzi following him down the street
and thousands of fans literally outside
his front door in New York City and he's
literally going please can you not come
to my home I watched the video of him
going please can you not come to my home
please and I go oh
man there's no way to live your life is
it that ambient anxiety there sort of
sense that you're being followed or that
that that something could go wrong yeah
uh yeah I I get you with that and I'm
I'm like I'm nowhere near some of these
people that live there like a drake or
even a Rogan or a or a Justin Bieber I
can't imagine going I teach you a lesson
that I learned from Ben Francis that
didn't happen on the podcast so we went
fernandos in Manchester uh at gym Shark
Lift La weekend and he'd got his EA to
text me and say where it was going to be
and when or maybe he' text me or
whatever um and I walk in and he sat
down reading something on his phone or
watching or whatever and I think is EA
and is EA's assistant or something has
sat on a different table he was just
there I sat down and we got talking for
the people who don't know Ben Francis is
the CEO of Jim shark and his net worth
is three times what Drake is worth
triple Drake and then I thought what
would the experience have been like if I
tried to come to this Nando with
Drake and Drake wouldn't have got within
two miles yeah of this he would have
been mobbed he would have been swamped
it would have been chaos there would
have been you can even even do this
thing there's like a law right where if
a normal person if like a super super
famous person turns up in a very crowded
place that they can be it's like
inciting violence vicariously through
fame or some [__] and it made me
start to think about the price that
people pay for the wealth that they have
right Ben Francis has managed to
accumulate an awful lot of wealth and
the felt price that he has to pay is at
the very least three times less than
Drake right because he doesn't have to
have security with him he no security
his EA is like 5 foot6 100 100 what's
the cost of in Ben's case of not being
as famous of the game he's chosen to
play which is business versus I suppose
that you know he's he's he's not going
to be get the public Accolade as much he
won't get access to as many cool things
because people aren't going to be
constantly looking for him he's not like
the the hot girl on your arm that you
can Trot out at some event he's very
rarely going to be that front seat at
the Lakers game and it pan and going and
here's the CEO of Jim shark Ben Francis
for me that's like pu he's not going to
get but the cost he's going to encounter
is seven days a week he's got thousands
of people who are relying on him to pay
their mortgages that me how many
people's Drake got relying on him
honestly on the business side of things
probably directly not that many Ben's
the CEO which means that when the
markets go down and when they go public
which I'm sure they'll go public when
that stock price dips as You' we've seen
from mat molding at the h group Matt
molding said to me again not a famous
not a drake right so to see of the Hut
group he said on stage actually at the
um an event we did at SoHo Farmhouse he
says sometimes at night I just lie on
that cold kitchen floor at 3:00 a.m.
because it's just cold and it's cooling
me down like the the the chaos of what's
going on in that company means that he's
lying at 3:00 a.m. on the kitchen floor
because it's just the coldest surface he
can feel to cool his body that that
level of like the hardest times of my
life were running business they weren't
like dealing with journalists it was
like the pressure of knowing payroll is
tomorrow and looking at the bank balance
and knowing there's nothing in there and
then looking up in the office and seeing
200 people in our HQ that are joyous and
celebrating because they think it's
payday tomorrow and me knowing in my
head that I have 24 hours to persuade
Natalie at our bank to put money in our
account or else they're not getting paid
the pressure of that is much worse than
any article or getting mobbed at Nando
and that's what Ben will be encountering
he'll do he does it with such Grace as a
lot of CEOs do but you've heard about
you know Elon Musk talking about the
pain of trying to save Tesla and SpaceX
being out in the street on Christmas Eve
like crying he says it's the deepest
pain he's ever felt then he got that
phone call that someone was going to
lend him 20 million to save Tesla and
and SpaceX it's a different level of
pain different game they're playing so
all things in life have a cost this is
my conclusion Drake's thing has a cost
which is privacy and all of those issues
Ben's thing has a cost as well which is
even thinking about it gives me
goosebumps cuz I know the feeling of
like The Angst of a business a [__]
yeah um they're two different costs and
it goes back to what you said is with
the Mark Manson quote which which cost
are you willing to to incur for which
rewards you've got an interesting idea
deep expertise is often a recipe for
rigidity it goes back to what we said a
second ago and that was those were the
words I was actually looking for when we
were talking about how knowing too much
about a thing can make you unable to be
agile and Innovative and think from
first principles and that when we think
about the real innovators over the years
that disrupted the incumbents it's very
rarely an that disrupts itself it's so
often a couple of kids in a base
basement that didn't go to university
that have seen the introduction of a new
technology and they thought let's [__]
around with this and they've been able
to displace a century old incumbent
because they are not incumbered by the
rigidity of convention yeah that from a
personal perspective I came up with a
name uh the vestigal pattern bias it
turns out it's also got it already
existed before I came up with it called
the Ein Stelling effect so the
successful deliberate approaches that we
learned during our development can
become a prison which stops us from
being more free flowing and at ease when
we are developed the tools that got you
from not to 50 are not the same ones
that get you from 50 to 90 or 90 to 95
but we found success with this approach
in the past so we cling on to an overly
rational deliberate approach we hope
that applying pure cerebral horsepower
to a situation will fix it without
realizing that our subconscious has
aggregated the thousands of hours of
experience that we've clocked up now and
not using that experience is keeping us
in the same league we've always been in
it's so interesting it's a prison you've
built around yourself that you don't
know is there and I reflect on that
video have you ever seen that video of
the ant in the pen no they get an ant on
a piece of paper plain A4 piece of paper
and the guy on YouTube It's like got
millions of views on YouTube Just with a
brro draws a circle around the Ant and
the Ant runs to the edge of the circle
and believes it's trapped and it will
not cross that line it will not cross
that line looking down on it from a
bird's eye view you go oh no it's just a
figment of its imag in they get they do
the same with a spider they get a piece
of paper there's a little spider on it
they draw a circle around it with a brro
it will not cross that line as the guy's
drawing the circle smaller and smaller
he accidentally draws it so close to the
spider that the spider steps over the
brro and then it can never ever in its
life be trapped by the Bro again and you
watch it just run off the page and he's
trying to trap it again and it can never
because it realizes that that that's
just a wall it's built in its mind and I
reflect on that always in my life and go
there was this time I was in Boston and
I was running on a tread machine and I
always do 10 kilm on this tread machine
and when I do 10 km I get this
physiological signal that I'm tired like
my my muscles break down I landed in
Boston I've got a talk later that day
the tread machine doesn't have the
kilometer dial on it so I can't see how
fast I'm running so I think okay I'll do
it the other way around I'll wait for
the signal in my body telling me I'm
tired and then I'll get off I run and I
run and I run and I run I run and I run
I run I'm like I'm not getting tired I
keep running running run running I look
up at the T I'm going to have to get off
this treadmill at some point I hit the
button 21
km and I and I was perplexed Leed
absolutely perplexed every time I run 10
km I feel knacked I ran 22 when I
couldn't see the thing and I don't it
was just a a limiting belief a wall I'd
built and I told myself that I was that
was my limit and you me we have drawn
circles around ourselves and those
circles are determining how far we push
how far we aim the the things we decide
to do but they are just figments of our
imagination have you seen there was a
study very famous study where they put
rats into water and they let them tread
water tread water tread water to see how
long they would do it until they just
gave up so first iteration of the study
they put rats in and I think they last
around about 30 minutes something like
that not long second iteration of the
study new rats obviously unfortunately
rats go in for 28 minutes then they pull
them out they dry them off and they let
them calm down then they put them back
in they tread water for like 12 hours
right really because their belief is I'm
going to be saved that's a learned
helplessness right you have heard about
the dog where it pushes the button to
stop from being electrocuted on the
floor it's the same sort of thing but
yeah I do
wonder what where where are the lines
that are drawn around us that we've
drawn around ourselves and especially
since moving to America my ambition has
changed so much I don't have a massive
amount of ambition intrinsically or I
didn't and then I start to hang around
with guys like Bill Perkins right or
Rogan or Mark Norman or you know people
that are really like moving very very
quickly and it's like through [__]
osmosis man you just can't not start to
have bigger goals and dreams and it's
scary it's scary when you realize
especially for me because I know what
it's like to not have ambition I don't I
not that it doesn't come for me but for
some reason I hadn't lit the fire that
went underneath it and then after a
little while you realize oh hang on a
second like this is really [__]
potent for you on that point about the
limitations we both have that uh we
probably don't realize are there the the
best place to always search I think is
in the labels we've given ourselves
like what do you label yourself as when
you introduce yourself podcaster yeah
and and the if you think about labeling
Theory what we said earlier about grades
or telling kids certain things that is
building a wall around you in your own
mind that you're a podcaster and this
happens in all of our Lives the last
thing we achieved becomes the identity
that we embody and it traps us in a cage
so I'm super careful all the time
especially when I left my last marketing
company to not Define myself with a
particular label because I would become
the label I would act in service of the
label and move in Direction you are not
a podcaster in fact like podcasting did
wasn't even a thing when you were born
so how can that be who you are you are
someone that is curious and this is what
I mean by like resisting the labels you
are curious you like intellectual
conversations you like um
self-improvement and forward motion and
if those are your labels think about all
the things you can apply that to
business and creativity and you're doing
shows soon right and I think that's a
fre and you look at why people get
midlife crises when they hit you know 40
30 40 years years old when they look at
how the hell did I get here I'm working
in the city well you you embodied a
label and lived that label for 15 years
and it wasn't even something you
particularly enjoyed you were just good
at it that resisting of labels I think
is so important for long-term happiness
so part of the reason why I went and
worked in psychedelics part of the
reason why I did the musical learned a
DJ wrote the books because I don't see
myself as anything I don't see myself as
social media marketing CEO social media
didn't exist when I was born there must
be something more fundamental to to who
I am and staying attached to that and
resisting at all cost society's prep um
temptation to put you in a box so we
understand you and we understand where
you
fit don't get in the Box it's more
difficult at a cocktail party but yeah I
I know I I don't I don't disagree I
don't I like entrepreneur because it's
broad it means you create stuff yeah
creative writer Etc all those things are
great yeah your skills are worthless but
your context is
valuable yeah just a really interesting
observation I've had from observing some
of the
most the people that have made huge
pivots in their life but also my own
experience of being a social media
marketing CEO for 10 years and then upon
leaving that business where I sold you
know I did marketing for big fashion
brands and big consumer electronics
Brands six months to a year after I left
there I moved my skill set to the
Biotech Industry because one of my
friends built one of the biggest
psychedelics companies in the world and
my skill set of social media and
marketing was in such low Supply in that
industry that the offer he made me to
join his business was outstanding and I
often think about you know we think the
way to get ahead in life is to get
promotions or to ask our boss for pay
rise but if you think about your core
skill set and the market in which you're
selling your skill set is it in low
Supply in that market and is the upside
for the person that is hiring me
tremendous you can get paid so much more
they offered me $8 million in options
for 9 months of work there's no fast
fashioned brand that would have offered
me that because the return for the fast
fashion brand would have been 20,000
more dresses sold in the Biotech
Industry it was moving that IPO price
from potentially 1 billion to three
billion so they could off 8 million is a
a flash in the pan one of my best
friends spent a long time in Manchester
designing nightclub Flyers getting paid
50 Quid 100 pound per flyer I probably
employed him you probably did yeah and I
remember in in Co being in his house and
the guy was like really down and out
he's like something needs to change in
my life I'm 35 now I'm still doing the
same old thing and his talent object L
his talent for design incredible
incredible but he was selling that skill
of design in the wrong Market nightclub
Flyers where you might get a couple more
people coming through the door um and in
an industry where it was abundant in
terms of supply of that skill so we made
this big wall in his house and we put up
um a few things where is your skill set
going to be in the least Supply and
where is this luxury design style you
have going to be in the highest demand
and also looking at industries that were
coming into Shore where his design
skills could yield the greatest returns
should be quite obvious as I say
this Dubai and
nfts artists suddenly came into fashion
the web 3 Community moved to Dubai so he
picked up his life from Manchester two
years ago and he moved to Dubai and this
guy is making millions now selling the
exact same skill to a different Market
where it's in low Supply but it's
yielding a greater return for those that
hire him and I think and I went through
in my book all the different industries
from writing to um acting to um creative
Pursuits where if you just moved
yourself from a different Market from
the market you run to a different Market
you'd get yield a greatest return and
lastly where I noticed this most is when
our company went public we went public
on a fairly small redundant German Stock
Exchange and in those rooms in Frankford
when I sat with Barkley's and um a
variety of different banks the thing
they kept on saying is if we uplist over
to the NASDAQ that the company will both
be worth three times more and I remember
thinking to myself so the same business
just moved to a different stock market
the market cap would multiply by three
that's kind of a metaphor for this idea
that maybe your skill set is currently
existing on an in lucrative and un
lucrative market and all you need to do
is find the market where it's in lowest
Supply and yields the greatest return
for those that need it and honestly
biotech is one of them well I mean since
moving to America it's the first time
that I've ever been in another country
where I've spoken the language but I've
also somehow been considered exotic do
you know what I mean like it's same
thing I'm the same person they can
understand me like you know going to
bellus or somewhere you you're different
you're you're different but where you
speak the same language you're the same
but somehow still exotic no one that's
ever been British has been called exotic
right apparently you could be doing this
exact same thing in sford radio station
to 77 listeners and there's so many as
the exact same thing the exact same
podcast the exact same talent that you
have but in the wrong Market where that
the economics of the business that
you're applying your skill set in aren't
there to give you to reap the greatest
returns and the the ceiling because of
the constraints of radio and the time
constraints just aren't there to get the
best out of your your talent and the the
value from your talent so I think it's
just a different lens to look through
because so many people want a nicer
house or a faster car and they're
thinking okay so I work here for three
years and I'll get a promotion and I'll
get there but there's another lens to
look through which is my core skill set
what is it and where can I get the
greatest return for it and where is it
in the least Supply it's a different
frame to think through but I yeah it's
it's life-changing for the right people
came up with this idea called Mono
thinking this week after I read a quote
from a friend you can gauge someone's
Ignorance by the number of phenomena
they explain with the same answer those
who blame many different issues like War
poverty and pollution on just one cause
capitalism are recycling explanations
because their demand for answers
outstrips the
supply and I like the idea of calling it
mono thinking it's another a explanation
for me about why people who are not
extremist cookie cutter ideologues
get criticized an awful lot
so if I know one of your views and from
it I can accurately predict everything
else that you believe they're not your
views you're not a serious thinker right
you have adopted a onesie wholesale and
you've decided to put this
on now the disadvantage is you haven't
thought for yourself and you don't
actually know what you're talking about
the advantage from a group scenario is
that I can very accurately predict what
you're going to think about the next
thing because it's what everyone else is
going to think about the next thing
right in your tribe yeah precisely
correct now the problem that you
encounter is that it makes you an
unreliable
Ally if your particular set of views
doesn't fall into this cookie cutter
design like there is no reason why your
view on abortion should relate to your
view on immigration or on economic
policy or on Healthcare or on gun
control or on Joe Biden or on whether
January 6 was a thing and whether aliens
are actually happening and yet for a lot
of people it does and there will be some
skew right some people will be more
likely but it shouldn't be that you have
the cookie cutter ideology of this
particular group the disadvantage of
being someone who doesn't take their
ideology wholesale like
that and this is the term that I loved
about it was you basically become an
unreliable I yeah sure you're with us on
abortion but what about Donald Trump you
weren't with us on that so what about
when the next thing happens I don't
actually know I don't actually know if
we should trust Steven so much and it's
not it's not an actual thought but it's
just something that sits in the back of
their mind and it it really um I think
it's comforting to people who maybe
sometimes feel like they are ostracized
from a group they're a rugby player and
they're there with the boys and they do
the training and they do all the rest of
it but they're not that bothered about
going out and getting smashed on a
Saturday night
and they feel like they're they're like
a little bit outside of the group
because of but I do the main thing with
you I do the thing that we're supposed
to be together for and yet I'm made to
feel outside of the group in the main
thing because I don't do the other thing
why is the other thing a part of the
main thing do you know what I mean does
that make sense I mean it goes back to
what we said earlier about one of the
issues in our psychology is we don't
want to be different in any way and
there's a real comfort in the Conformity
of the
crowd so it's much easier to not realize
that most most truth is in the middle
somewhere it's much it's much more
comfortable and creates that sense of
belonging in the same way that identity
and labels do to fit into the crowd and
accept 95% of what my of the people that
wear the same football kit as me wear if
the socks are different someone's going
to point it out sitting in the middle is
is there's just no there's no home there
there's no team there's no safety in the
middle um but the truth is in the
middle and so it's a decision you have
to make about your strength of
conviction and what you care about
what's your kpi success is it truth or
is it
Conformity um but it's tough that's why
I love so much about podcasting is we've
created a bit of nuance in the medium
it's not just Echo Chambers and
algorithms separating left and right
there's a diversity of opinion stretched
over two hours so there's context and I
think people that gravitate towards this
medium in shows like yours appreciate
Nuance they they're not looking for a
leftwing podcast or an all right podcast
whatever um It's Tricky it's really
really tricky in this day and age really
it takes a certain a certain strength
that most of us can't embody in our
pursuit of finding our tribe and fitting
in and avoiding self-preservation and
not being kicked off the island if you
think about it from an evolutionary
standpoint it would literally have led
to death if you didn't have a clear
tribe like if you didn't have a it would
have been kicked off the island would
have led to death so it's no wonder that
we we're so quick especially with the
aid of algorithms to fall into these
tribes and say and swear allegiance to
everything they believe yeah the the
other interesting thing is that and
absurd ideological belief is less about
what you believe in and more about
showing fty to the ideology overall I
learned this from the same guy ginda
that that did that quote he basically
said that if you have a really crazy
ideological belief let's say it's to do
with the world being flat you pick
whatever it is that you want it's kind
of like a a canary in the coal mine it's
like this is so counter to your rational
thought that if you're with us on this
we can probably reliably say that you're
going to be with us and all of this
other stuff right it's a show of fty
that's what's important about it and
when people don't adhere to that they're
seen as uncommitted by the
opposition and unreliable by their own
side and
also in their own view of who they are
it causes dissonance so if I say I'm
left leaning and then I encounter a
policy or a theory or some kind of idea
that is typically belongs to the right
my sense of identity on a psychological
level will be challenged and threatened
in in an really unhelpful way so in
order to alleviate the dissonance of who
I think I am I have to reject that idea
or else it throws you into this state
which psychologists called dissonance
where you have like there's something
contradictor what contradicting what I
think I know about myself and who I am
in the world so we have to throw it out
this is why we most people can't even
have a conversation with someone that
they know disagrees with them it's why
they unfollow and block people because
it's causing dissonance the truth
popping up on their timeline and being
something that challenges their sense of
identity or their ability to be as far
on the left or as far on the right as
possible it's not nice for ourselves
it's actually I think much of it is
actually the threat it poses to
ourselves in our own mind the identity
threat it's like a psychological
protection mechanism I said I was on the
left I said I was a labor supporter
that's who I am that's the Friendship
group I've built that's how I understand
myself this new piece of information
okay that's a right leaning thought I
can't if I if I if I entertain that I
have to entertain dissonance cognitive
friction so the easiest thing to do is
shoot at the person who said it
discredit them yeah or find some way to
just you know kill it on site and that's
the thing can you deal with dissonance I
think many of the greatest thinkers in
our world are able to sit in dissonance
for long enough to interrogate something
for its merits yeah being able to hold
two contradictory thoughts in your mind
at the same time is like very valuable
but increasingly rare do you follow
people that disagree with you and no
even further do you follow people that
really piss you off when they tweet
because of their ideas are so far from
your own me person no I I keep my I keep
my Twitter following below 100 which
means that it's it's it's difficult to
get in there but certainly on Instagram
yes uh a bunch of my
friends have extoled to me the
importance and the virtue of exposing
yourself to content that you
purposefully disagree with I actually
listen to a number of different podcasts
that are like typically wouldn't be the
sort of thing that I would listen to but
it really gives me an interesting
Insight so um decoding the gurus can
spirituality um QQ andon Anonymous
interesting those are three of them and
they're like sort of Center left or left
leaning like debunking kind of shows
there's a lot of criticism of like I've
been criticized on those shows there's
criticism of people that are in my
industry uh that are my friends but I
find it really interesting to observe
what someone who isn't me sees and
that's been very Illuminating really
really Illuminating it's not so easy to
hear hear it when it's about you but um
yeah I find that very interesting do you
know what's interesting when you see how
someone on the other side let's just say
on the other side of the belief system
feel so strongly about something that
you just think is absolutely absurd like
the Flat Earth or whatever you know it
also tells you a story about your own
beliefs and one that if if you if you
observe closely is probably the most
important thing you can learn which is
like my beliefs are also based probably
on the same fundamentals like I heard
something from somewhere it confirmed
the the way I wanted the world to be it
probably came from people that I agreed
95% of things on otherwise um and the
fragility of belief so the fragility of
all the beliefs you have about you and
you what you're capable of and who you
are if if that person over there is so
clearly completely
wrong maybe I am too at a really
fundamental level I actually I've been
thinking it's been creeping into my mind
over the last couple of weeks that like
maybe the person I think I
am as we kind of said earlier is is not
actually who I am and it's just a bunch
of beliefs that I've like I'm living by
like those disciples on the left and
right do and like how do I unpack all of
that and find out who who I can be and
who I really am what would I have to do
what's the journey I'd have to go
on
so this is why we all deluded we're all
deluded so fundamentally you know we
both speak about this a good bit I think
and I wonder whether part of it's
because were from the UK and for the
American people that are listening it
might not make quite as much sense
although if you're from some small town
in the midwest maybe it does there is
such a strong pull for people to conform
in the UK perfect example look at the
vaccination rates I think it's like 90
93 94% of people in the UK got their
first dose uh it's like sort of high 80
second and then like low 80s third right
I think America maybe scraped the bottom
of a dick of 50 or 60 for the first dose
right but who are the Americans in the
room they're a nation of people who said
yeah [__] it I'll get on that boat right
the British people I don't know maybe
there's genetic predisposition maybe
it's cultural imposition probably a part
of both but I certainly see in the UK a
fear of breaking out and and very very
strong criticism when people do and if I
could bring back if I could export from
my life in the US and import to the
world of the UK uh one thing it would be
a lack of cynicism like it would be less
cynicism around people doing different
things because I think that it's
stifling happiness flourishing
Innovation people leading a life that's
that's different to the one that they
would do being more experimental being
more motivated uh yeah I I I really wish
that I could like sprinkle a little bit
of that motivation you know the first
Brit that's moved to the LA that works
especially in the creative Industries
that has said that to me there you're
not the second you're not the third
you're not the fourth you're not the
fifth say I hear it all the time and you
hear it even when you thinking about
Innovation and we even see on the London
Stock Market now the public company CEOs
that I know that flirted on the stock
market are just being destroyed they're
like personal character is being
destroyed and the stocks are in the bin
you think about some of the big unicorns
we've had from the UK being the founders
of those is just an awful experience if
they were in the US they would be
applauded and clapped and on the front
cover of you know whatever [__] I wish
we could change torn to they're Torn to
Pieces here it feels like there's a
little bit of something going on here
too LS Capaldi you watch his documentary
yeah how I'm feeling now I think it's
called um had him on the podcast as well
so yeah I really enjoyed that uh he's
got this one line in it that I just
[__] can't stop thinking about leis
Capaldi writes this first album songs
that he was singing since 2017 when he
was playing them in working men's pubs
all around the Northeast of
Scotland then he blows up trillion
bazillion
streams and he's asked to write the
second album during coid WME or CA or
whoever his recording company are how's
the album coming along and he's feeling
this pressure and he develops this tick
because he's under all of this
anxiety and he's noticing he has stayed
the same right he is still the same
person that he was from
before and he's noticing the world
treating him in a different way and he's
scared and he's a uncertain about his
own abilities and about what the world
wants from him and he can't work out why
other people are treating him
differently this [__] one line in the
middle of the documentary he says Fame
doesn't change you just changes
everybody around you
yeah and it seems to be as far as I can
tell the truth that a lot of people feel
especially someone like Lewis the same
songs it's literally the songs that he
wrote from before and when you see the
CEO the business owner the rugby player
that's trying to break out and do things
differently as you ascend in status as
you change the world around you as you
start to become more competent as the
texture of your own mind
improves other people will notice the
difference in you more quickly than you
do and in poor versions of culture they
won't respond nicely to it they won't
respond well and I wish that we could
somehow just [__] get rid of that in
the UK and you'll even you probably
would have observed this as a podcaster
but speaking to Daniel pink who's the
you know great
motivational speaker I guess researcher
he talks about how when your incentive
structures of performing a behavior
change and it becomes
about making sure the people at your
record label can pay their mortgages the
enjoyment of the pursuit of the thing
itself decreases think about the
discipline equation friction goes way up
the psychological enjoyment of the
pursuit is no longer you in the corner
of the pub in L kali's case where he
said to me I want to go back to the pub
like that's basically what he's saying
sometimes I just wish I could go back to
the pub where no one knew my name and I
had to shout over people as they were
drinking their beers and ignoring me
less pressure more psychological
enjoyment less friction um so you got to
be careful I think this is what Rogan
has done so unbelievably well we think
about building decad Long Systems that
will endure in the face of status and
Temptation Rogan has said I'm going to
stick to my principles and I'm not going
to do a podcast one single episode that
I don't love a conversation I don't want
I I I'm not going to do a single
conversation I don't want to have
whether it's my boy from The Comedy
Store talking about anthills or whatever
I'm going to stay true to my principles
incredibly difficult to do you know he's
done it perfectly keep his Circle small
try and stay away from those red carpets
as much as he possibly can and keep his
principles laser focused why did I start
this and I can't imagine the pressure
he's had why don't you have more of
these people on why don't you have more
of this type of person on you should all
the Articles writing you change your
principles change your what that's a
motivation threat and he's managed to
saave off that motivation threat for 15
years would you know why it's so
important to not damp that down is
because your instincts are so
idiosyncratic and personal to you and if
you try to reverse engineer what you
think you should be doing the only thing
that you have which was your instincts
are going to be eroded away yeah that's
all that you've got ultimately like you
you're show and mine despite the fact
that we traffic in very similar circles
we're friends with a lot of the same
people we even cross over in terms of
guests listen to the [__] episode it
could not there could not be a better
person
for to be crossing over with me in
British podcasting because our vend
diagram Circles of how we have our
conversations are [__] completely
different and that's perfect right
because I couldn't do your show you're
interested in stories right you
fundamentally love stories you love the
passion behind people you love the
emotions that are driving that you want
to understand why they are the way they
are I want ideas right I want to
understand what's the framework that
seen how does this apply in a different
setting right that's [__] great so
Douglas Murray tells me this story right
one of my favorite stories Douglas one
of the first newspapers that he works at
he has this boss who's like a legendary
Sant of the journalist journalism
industry and he decides he's going to
release a uh West End show about the
life of Prince Charles in rhyming
couplets and this guy's like at the
Zenith of his career so he's this big
dog and there's going to be loads of
scrutiny and he's been in the journal
industry so he's probably made a [__]
ton of enemies as well anyway opening
night by the halftime interval there was
no one left in the entire Auditorium
including the cast so this guy's
despondent egg on his face articles upon
articles upon articles about how
embarrassing it was and Douglas asked
him he said what were you thinking
[__] show in the West End of London
about the life of Prince Charles in
rhyming coulet he saidwell Douglas I
trusted my instincts an instincts that
may sometimes lead you wrong but they're
the only thing that's ever led you right
I was like holy [__] that's true and if
you don't listen to your instincts in
that regard you can actually get
yourself to the stage where you've
eroded them away and you've pushed them
away so much you can't really hear them
anymore and then you're no better than
the guys on Late Night show TV who don't
actually run their own show they're the
mouth puppet of whatever the big egac
and the big company and their agenda is
that sits behind them and if you want to
feel a great regret in life it's making
a decision against your instinct and
then it failing making a decision in
line with your instinct and then it
failing is much less of a place to fall
from than making an in making a decision
against your instincts and then it fails
and I've sat with so many people in the
media Industries who've done daytime
talk shows I actually had one of my
podcast and she said to me G you know
the part that hurts the most is I knew
the show
sucked and I didn't speak out and say it
didn't I always say to my team and I've
said this to my manager who's in the
room now I said we're doing a new TV
show right and I said to him I want to
fail at something that I believe in
because failing at something that I
didn't believe in will suck more than
any pain in my life so if I fa if I do
something and I believed in it and it
was in line with my instincts and I fail
you go cool right okay I've learned
something here but God can you imagine
the
regret of acting out against your
instincts and then it going badly
like so on all facets of my life that's
like that's my um my thing going forward
is fail at something you believe in you
know you can't predict the output you
can't predict whether there's product
Market fit in most walks of life but the
input of you you know you being glad
that it was in line with your principles
Your Instinct and your values you just
got to Hope on the on the outside that
it resonates with someone else and
typically the truth is you know they say
when you're Building Products or
businesses don't create for someone you
haven't met create for your best friend
because there'll be lots more people
like you and your best friend and you
know your best friend best and I always
think about that when I when we're
making like the trailers for the podcast
or we're doing pieces of content for
client I think which one of my friends
is go I always say this to people I say
I say we say to my team tell me now
which one of your friends is going to
share that in the WhatsApp group and
that's not a rhetorical question I want
to know his name because if there's one
of them there'll be Millions so they'll
go okay um my friend Dave he's going
through this divorce at the moment and
actually I need to change this bit
because in Dave's through the lens of
Dave Dave's life i' actually probably
need to take out this little part and
emphasize this and when you create stuff
through that lens you make stuff that's
resonant at scale
it's a nice frame to run whenever you
make something name the friend that this
is for and why they're going to pick it
up and put it in the WhatsApp group or
share it on their story or love it or
buy it or click or
care wonderful frame stepen Bartlett
ladies and gentlemen Stephen I
appreciate the hell out of you man what
you do next great question um loads of
meetings back toback hopefully we go for
dinner tonight here in London yep yeah
that'll be great um just yeah working I
work working out probably in about an
hour's time um lots of things what about
you what are you up to
next uh we're going to do some
interesting stuff back here in London at
the end of October I'm really excited
for this I'm going to try and do a new I
can't say it yet because if it doesn't
happen it's going to be disappointing
I'm going to try and do something
relatively new in podcasting that I
don't think has quite been done before
it's least it's not been done for quite
a while um and then live show like a
live thing no okay no no no um a round
table I I I'll I'll tell you off Fair
I'll tell you off fair when when I can't
get hell to account if it doesn't happen
um I'm looking forward to that uh live
tour UK and isand at the end of this
year then US and Canada I'll be doing a
little bit of work around there with
James Smith we got a show in Dubai
toward the end of November and I need a
break man I need a Christmas I'm looking
I'm working toward December now so how
do you know you need a break uh actually
I don't I don't know that I need a break
I just feel like it would be
rejuvenative haven't seen Mom and Dad
much this year um but yeah resilience is
a strange thing it comes it creeps up on
you you don't mean to build it and then
it just appears yeah you don't really
know dude I appreciate you I really do I
appreciate the fact that we we support
each other throughout what it is that
we're doing I I really want to give you
a big compliment because there's very
few people you encounter in this game
that it's so abundantly clear that
they're acting in line with their
principles like they're leading with
their curiosity and it shows in the
consistency of what you do that you're
someone that is like creating from first
principles you're led by what you
actually care about and that's it's
really inspiring for me to see it's
really inspiring that's why I was so in
a Fred again cuz I was like this is a
person that's acting on his own
curiosity and first principles and I see
that in you and I know how that plays
out it's an amazing amazing thing game
recognizes game man thank you brother
appreciate you thank you thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode with Steven then press here for
the fulllength 3-hour long podcast with
Alex hosi which has been blowing
people's minds go on press
it